Õpetaja: Jah, jah, no las ta siis rekordib. Ee, las ta siis rekordib ka selle osa peale.
Õpetaja: Ma teen Ee. Screenshare. I
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Ee Teeme. Siis korda. Asjad mis vajasid veel tähelepanu.
Õpetaja: Mis ee profiil sa oled? Henri?
Õpetaja: Millega sa siis oled?
Õpetaja: Okei, ja nii
Õpetaja: Niimoodi Eri on siin ka nüüd olemas.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan, kas sa oled mulle oma slackpot I saatnud.
Õpetaja: Ma usun küll, Ma lihtsalt ei ole siia võibolla lisanud. Ma loodan, et ma olen sinna õigesse kohta.
Õpetaja: Näed siin on olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Nii, see on ka olemas. Madis, ma vaatan Ee, sina oled ka kindlasti saatnud.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on Sinust Läks vot.
Õpetaja: Eile saatsid ma korra? Vaatan selle heaks juhuks üle. See oli kooliajal, Ahah, siis ma arvatavasti ikka lisasin. Nii
Õpetaja: ma korra vaatan. Võibolla ühe reegli. Ikkagi vaatan üle üle. Vaata, et number viis
Õpetaja: saate näha ka See töötab umbes niimoodi, et näete. Meil on neid. Meil on eraldi mailboxid
Õpetaja: ja siia tulevadki. Meile tulevad need sõnumid. Lihtsalt on reegel, et Iga Kord kui Verify gate, siis on, ee, meil siin tehtud Niuke uhkus, pookus,
Õpetaja: et, ee, Ütleme et kui tuleb sisse sõnum Verifying It You, Siis ole hea. Saada need
Õpetaja: nendele aadressidele, mis on siin ja ma näen. Siin. On see Henri oma ka või Madis, kes iganes See oli et lihtsalt automaatselt läheb meil
Õpetaja: edasi. Ja see on siis teie, et, ee, Slack on lihtsalt teinud niukse integratsiooni, et sa saad Lihtsalt saata nagu meili Ja see tuleb sulle Sinna
Õpetaja: Ongi see, et sa lihtsalt tahad, teada tuleb mingisugune sinu jaoks mingi tähtis asi. Võibolla Mailbox Ei, vaata. Slack on kogu aeg lahti. Põmm tuleb. Sinna Saate isiklikus elus seda ka kasutada. Kui tahate, et ta nagu genereerib lihtsalt emaili aadressi, mis tuleb Slacki muud midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma arvan. Nüüd me oleme järjel igast Aa, minna asjadega. Ja nüüd ma tahaks rääkida teile, Ee, homsest
Õpetaja: homsega. Mul on selline plaan, et. Ee, ma lähen ise ära. Kuskil kaks kolmkümmend.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul on vaja minna ühte kohta Ma Kohe ütlen ka, kuhu ma lähen. See on tegelikult teie enda huvides.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, ee, et ee, seda aega sisustada,
Õpetaja: siis. Ee, okei, ma Räägin, kuhu ma lähen. Kõigepealt teeme siis kronoloogiliselt. Seda Ei, ma sain Niukse kutse.
Õpetaja: Mm, kuhu ma siis tahan? Minna Ee Eestis on Niukene organisatsioon. Olemas nagu itl. Mis, On infotehnoloogia liit vist midagi taolist
Õpetaja: ja. Siis on niukene Suurem arutelu kuhu, on kutsutud kohapeale Eesti niuksed ühed Suuremad. Ee, või? Noh, paar suuremat ettevõtte
Õpetaja: Ee arendusmeeskondade juhte rääkima. Teema on siis, see, et ai tööriistadest tulenev infotehnoloogia ametikohtade profiilide muudatus ainult koha peal.
Õpetaja: Ja see sisu on siis Aa, selline, et. Ee, ee, kus siin on?
Õpetaja: Mis need teemad on? Ee, osalege kaasa. Milliseid uusi Teadmisi ja oskusi tuleb tarkvaraarendajatele koolides või täiend ümberõppes õpetada,
Õpetaja: kuidas tagada olukorras, kus kohati kostub väljaütlemine noorem Juunior. Arendajaid ei ole vaja siiski Tarkvara arendajaid juurde juurdekasv. Kuidas sa tagada?
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla võimalikud sõnumid poliitikale järgmisel aastal mingi. Noh, see viimane asi, mind aega. Ei, huvita. Mind huvitavad need inimesed, kes siin esinevad. Ma siin näen ühe nime kohe ära. Keda ma tean, ma olen isegi temaga koos. Käinud, ma Isegi temaga koos Barcelonas hänginud. Hästi, tark inimene. Rain Kolk, Raino koik. Vabandust,
Õpetaja: ee meeletult Tark Aa telija. Seal mingil uhkel kohal priit liivakust Olen ka tegelikult kuulnud. Siin on ee, ühesõnaga ühed suuremad ettevõtted, kes siis tulevad, arutavad täpselt seda sama probleemi,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ai tööriistad teevad lihtsaid asju ära. No fakt, väga hästi ka, veel onju? Peale kauba. Ja nüüd ongi siis küsimus on see. Vaata, et probleem on nagu Selles, et oleks nagu rohkem vaja. Nagu Niukene, mitte juunior. Niuke meid level. No ütleme siis tarkvara arendaja Niuke tasemega inimesi.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga siis On see küsimus, Vaata see. Noh, kinni. Saba lahti, onju? Tead, ikka seda vana klassikalist asja? Vaata, kõik tahavad kogemusega kogemusega töötajat.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga Päriselus on see tegelikult väga ebarealistlik. Vaata, et ei saa kõik kogemusega inimest sellepärast, et siis ju mitte keegi ei saagi kogemust
Õpetaja: kõik inimesed, kes juurde tulevad?
Õpetaja: Ee, et ma lähen kindlasti siis sellele miitingule. Aa, lähen ka sellele arutelule vaatama, mis nad räägivad, Saab olema põnev.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kuidas tundub? Tundub põnev asi, kui minna ma kokkuvõtte teen. Kindlasti Ma ei julgen striimida seal või? Vaata. Ja tegelikult ee, mind asendab, Mul on juba asendaja olemas. Meil on siin õpetaja Rain.
Õpetaja: Nii, väga hea õpetaja. Ära muretse, sa oled. Aita läbi viia. Tehniline tugi, Aga õp. Keegi peab asja nagu koordineerima.
Õpetaja: Ee, homme.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis ma tahan. Aa, Praegult on hetkel täpselt seitse lauda. Confirmige, kas on nii Mind tehke välja, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus, Seitse on.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Ee. Minu mõte on selline.
Õpetaja: Homseks teile ülesanne, rühmatöö ja esitlus. Meile kõigile meeldivad rühmatööd.
Õpetaja: Vihkan täiega.
Õpetaja: Mulle üldse ei meeldi tegelikult, aga teile meeldib. Ee. Peab meeldima. Ee, kolmapäeval töötate rühmades ning valmistad ette lühikese esitluse ühe java opening teemade kohta.
Õpetaja: Teie eesmärk on selgitada teemad võimalikult lihtsalt ja arusaadavad. Mõelge nii, kas inimene, kes ei tea programmeerimisest. Tuhkagi saaks midagi aru.
Õpetaja: Üldised nõuded, tee. Rühm peab koostama esitluse, kasutades Powerpoint I või Google Slidesi. Noh, Google Slide lihtsam Aa selgitama teemat lihtsas keeles.
Õpetaja: Lisame vähemalt ühe päriselu näite. Mingisuguse analoogia. Sellepärast, et niimoodi inimesed oskavad kuidagi. Aa, vähemalt üks visuaal. Mingi jooniskeem, mida iganes
Õpetaja: Ee, näitama väikest java koodi näidet. Esitus peaks olema viis kuni kümme minutit pikk
Õpetaja: aa. Esitluse, struktuur aa. Mis, see on miks? On seda vaja näide kooliga päriselu näide joonis või skeem.
Õpetaja: Aa, rühmade teemad. Ee, rühm. Üks variabadus. Muutujad Mis on muutuja. Miks seda kasutatakse, mis on Erinevad andmetüübid Ja see on mingi näide ka. See on rühm. Kaks on If Ee. Ma muutsin ära. Ee Tahtsin selle teema. Ma muudan Ära Aa, siia. Teeme parem ifänd.
Õpetaja: See vestlus pooleli. Ee, nii, edasi ja nii edasi. Vahet pole, ee. Kuidas ma siis teen? On niimoodi, et me teeme niimoodi. Üks, kaks,
Õpetaja: palun.
Õpetaja: Neli, viis, kuus, teise sobib. Ee, mina lähen ära. Kuskil siis kaks, kolmkümmend.
Õpetaja: Ee, teil on, Ma Arvan Peaaegu circa. Ütleme peaaegu siis. Ee, peaaegu tund aega oleks aega seda valmistada. Ma annan teile teemad juba täna ära, nagu Selles mõttes Jagan ära, et siis iga grupp teab niiöelda nende nummerdatud. Ma teen pärast Copy base. Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: ee, et te siis juba saate tegelikult juba kodus mõelda. Vaata mis iganes, et. Ee. Homme siis, kui mina lähen, ära
Õpetaja: pange grupi peale kokku. Mingi esitlus. Arutage seda, kuidas oleks Võimalikult lihtne. Esitlused peavad tulema selles järjekorras nagu seal. Need tiimid on neli ja nii edasi. Kuna nad oleks kronoloogiliselt natukene, sõltuvad, ehk siis Teie ise tehke endale üks väikene tükk nii selgeks, kui saate.
Õpetaja: Proovige mõelda, kuidas seda võimalikult, Lihtsalt nagu selgitada
Õpetaja: tuues mingid näited analoogiad Ärge ääge Lihtsalt koodi kinni vaid. Proovige kuidagi mõelda see. On nagu teie creativity Nüüd. Ee, Õpetaja, rain. Vastutab et, ee kõik, noh. Rain, Õpetaja, Rain, siis. Ee, on see. Kes siis? Ee. Pärast proovime siia. Kas sul on kooliläpakas? Enda läpakas?
Õpetaja: Jah, ee. Proovime pärast sinu läpakaga. Ma Teen niimoodi. Kui ma ära lähen siis ma annan. Ee, sulle või kellele iganes Aeg pole, et. Ee, see Zoom jääb lahti.
Õpetaja: Zoom is On võimalik rekordi panna pausile ja panna rekordima pausile ja panna rekordima pausile panna rekordima. Ee, Raini arvuti jääb siis siia lihtsalt siia keskele, Ee, ja siis, ee, selles mõttes. Ee, see, ee. Mis iganes. Tiim teeb oma esitluse, saab lihtsalt teha Screenshare iga
Õpetaja: aga mikker on lahti, Vaata, sinu arvutises hit. Ainult üks mikker. Vot see on alati see mure. Vaata mikker ja heli, et ei ole nagu kasu. Näiteks ma Tahaks neid esitlusi ise ka pärast vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on mu mõte, et kui neli ei ole, siis on lihtsalt, niimoodi. Et te tulete Ja räägite siin,
Õpetaja: et see on sinna lähedal arusaadav
Õpetaja: ja ja väldime. Seda Teeme niimoodi lihtsalt, et Raini, Raini, raini jabra, vaata, sest et Siis tuleb nagu. Okei. Ee, mis on selge.
Õpetaja: Kellegil midagi küsimusi saab? Praegu saab teha küll. Ja siis, kui Free Trial on läbi, enam Ei tea,
Õpetaja: aga mis see
Õpetaja: Aa te saate teha? Ee, sinna. Siis hakkad nagu sõnumit kirjutama. Siis sa saad otsingust. Search Vaata, otsid näiteks Triinu ja Karinit.
Õpetaja: Ee, kirjutab mingisuguse. Tere, siis tal nagu tekib Niukene väikene grupp.
Õpetaja: Aga te saate pärast. Kui teil tekivad tiimid, siis te Teete päris nagu tiimi kanalit.
Õpetaja: Nagu kus ongi. Nagu permanentselt mingi ee ligipääs. Need võivad olla private Id Võivad olla. Räägime sellest hiljem
Õpetaja: et Te saate arutada. Ee, mis te arvate? Sobib,
Õpetaja: et siis on nagu tegelikult. Ka nagu ma nii või naa? Tegelikult jah,
Õpetaja: aga Google Google. Noh, see, mis ta. See, mis on Google endal olemas. On see mingi Google slides? Jah, See võib olla kõige lihtsam see siis
Õpetaja: jah, Tähendab selles mõttes, et piiranguid ei ole. Vaata, kama ja kamateid kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, Peamine mõte on see, et, ee, et see oleks Kvaliteetne sisu poolest. Ee, vormistus. Asjad Ai abiga või ilma ükstaspuha. Aga et te arutate läbi ja siin on üks väike baranka ka, te Peate olema valmis selleks ka, et kui ee, auditooriumis on mingeid küsimusi, siis te peaksite proovima vastata.
Õpetaja: Te peate lihtsalt spetsialiseeruma ühes konkreetses küsimuses
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, siis. Ee. Need teemad on niikuinii need asjad, millest me varsti jõuame, sinna. Ja me tahame, et te nagu neid mõistaksite.
Õpetaja: Vot nii selline plaan. Ja ma siis ise teen ka kindlasti mingisuguse homme. Mingi kokkuvõtte mida ma kuulen. Ee, sellest ee, miitingust, et kui Ma sain selle kutse. Mul tavaliselt ei meeldi kuskile minna, kui mul on koolitus. Eriti nii alguses. Lõpupoole on juba savi, no tal on Tiimitööd ja asjad. Vaata, juba, et see on nagu hästi lihtne.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga ma vaatasin, et see on niuke teema, mida ma ei saa Nagu mitte minna kohale. Mul. Isegi kui mul kolleeg läheb, siis ma ei taha seda. Noh, rääkisid seda ja toda. Vaata, ma tahan ise kuulda. Ma tahan kuulda, mis nad räägivad sel teemal, sest see on hästi aktuaalne teema,
Õpetaja: et mis? Mis? Ma olen kogu aeg seda mõelnud, Et mis kuradi moodi see asi nüüd hakkab olema? Nagu selles mõttes, et
Õpetaja: kui tulevad need arendajad, kui suund on see, et kasuta mai Tööriistu,
Õpetaja: mi? Mida me nüüd siis peame õpetama? Kas me ikkagi peame õpetama seda päris kogemist? Või peakski minema rohkem ai poole. Kuidas nad Siis nagu sul vive seal.
Õpetaja: Mida nad seal teevad Kuidas üldse nad on nagu tööturul Ka nagu, ee, siis võimelised seal niiöelda konkureerima, kui Kaid ootavad seda. Noh, Minu meelest on niuke tunne, et nad ootavad, et tase on nagu kõrgem,
Õpetaja: on ju? Nii
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et siin on ju see teema püstitus. Vaata, et käib justkui see, nagu see kõlks. Vaata et noorem arendajaid pole enam vaja. Vaata, on ju vaja.
Õpetaja: Davai teeb, ära, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, see väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ja,
Õpetaja: no seda võib nii mõelda.
Õpetaja: Seda võib nii mõelda, aga teistmoodi ka mõelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui kui Palju Te Kas keegi teab, kes Kuidas protsessor üldse töötab?
Õpetaja: No väga hea, homme esitlus. Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, Noh, ma korra nagu räägin, seda, vaata, Et, Ee, kuidas progemine alguses üldse oli? Olid, oli niuksed papist perfokaardid, kus olid nagu erinevates kohtades, oli võimalik nagu augud teha ja siis Masinad nagu põhimõtteliselt lugesid. Null ja üks üks ja null. Nagu ka enda, nagu see.
Õpetaja: Aga nagu väga algasel tasemel, niimoodi oli kunagi päris Alguses
Õpetaja: aga siis aeg läks edasi. Siis tuli nagu päris programmeerimine. Aga alguses oli assembler keel. Seal oli nagu mingi paari tähe ühikuga koosnevad Käsud nagu Vaata, mida protsessorile saab saata, onju?
Õpetaja: Niimoodi siis tuli esimene. Niiöelda, mida kutsutakse nagu. Mis oli esimene programmeerimisskeem, mis nagu meenutas juba Nagu midagi, mis täna on. No, põhimõtteliselt nagu täna. Ingliskeelsed sõnad ja asjad ja kirjutavad poodi
Õpetaja: pandi, on nagu jaavaga, nagu väga valge versioon. Sellest midagi taolist. Tulid niuksed keeled,
Õpetaja: nii. Ja siis. Noh, see asi on nagu nii kaugele arenenud, et et iga kord igal igal nii öelda, etapil on toimunud abstraktsioon. Selles mõttes, et me tegelikult ei tea, mis? Seal allpool toimub,
Õpetaja: et, ee, isegi selles mõttes et ma mõtlen, Kas see assembler kood läheb lõpuks nullideks ja ühtideks. Protsessor ei mõista mingisuguseid käske Selles mõttes Tal on ikkagi vaja nullideks ja ühtedeks bike Kood, nullid, ühed nullid, ühendid Panevad. Kaheksa numbri kaupa Näiteks,
Õpetaja: et et selles mõttes et see päris algeline Phitide aeg on möödas,
Õpetaja: see on Ära lahendatud ja see toimib.
Õpetaja: Seda ei ole vaja enam nagu mõelda.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis tuli see assemblerge, mis oli natukene parem, lõpuks ise sealt Valmis on? Ju? Assemblergale oli ka mingisugune rõve. Asi, Vaata mida? Nagu täna keegi ei tahaks. Teha,
Õpetaja: kui tulidki need High Level keeled nagu Ja kõik need muud. Vaata hiljem, on ju Nüüd me saame kirjutada nagu sõnu ja asju. Ja see on miiniful Me ei pea teadma Need endised, need vanad protsessid sellelt. Ee, kõik toimuvad endiselt seal taustal allpool,
Õpetaja: aga tekib iga hetkela konstruktsioon nagu sihtkõrgemale et me ei tea, Tegelikult, mis seal nagu sügavamal all toimub?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma pakun, et see. Noh, see loovus ja Ai ja kõik see vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: eks? Ta on evolutsioonis Järgmine samm. Ma mõtlen nagu selles mõttes, et Kas te tõesti arvate et ta, näiteks saja aasta pärast, nagu programmeerimine on nagu Selline nagu sa täna,
Õpetaja: kui kui me täna näeme juba. Ai, D, on ju? Me ei peagi teadma. Neid ei huvitagi tegelikult
Õpetaja: kui Fantastiliselt ilus kood see on Või kui kole kood. See on Vähemalt saja aasta pärast inimest. Mitte,
Õpetaja: sest et meie tööriistad on juba siis teistsugused. Language.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt räägi loogika niimoodi. Tee seda toda, on ju? Ja taustal See kõik on olemas, et, ee, võibolla lihtsalt ei olegi seda loovust enam ühel hetkel vaja Aga täna me ei ole seal. Kindlasti
Õpetaja: Kindlasti mitte süsteemne Üks mees,
Õpetaja: üks mees, kui vist läheb kuni paidini välja, Ossaar, raisk. Mis palganumber tal on? On ju läbi selle protsessori.
Õpetaja: Tore, eks ju? Ja
Õpetaja: jah, vot selle sellega Lihtsalt eks see aeg teeb. Ena oma töö, et ma ei kujuta ette, kas päriselt maamunal on ka veel inimesi, kes nagu kuidagi, näiteks ka seda koodi mingil kujul näpivad. Ilmselt on ja ilmselt ilmselt on neid inimesi ja ilmselt on ka vajadus. Vaata, nagu, et jah on,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, ütleme niimoodi Ikka nagu väga kaugemas. Ee, muusikas. Nagu ma pigem ikkagi näen, et see asi eriti. Ai, mis, nagu on arenemas, nagu see on ikkagi Baby. Praegult ju.
Õpetaja: See A ja värk ikkagi tegelt. On Pita hingede särk. Jah,
Õpetaja: tegelikult, kui kaua sai? On olnud kaua ei olnud?
Õpetaja: No Räägime natuke nagu. Nagu, umbes Tänapäeval On
Õpetaja: jah midagi taolist, aga tegelikult see on ikkagi suht Uus teema. Vaata, on ju, et, ee, aga, Noh, varsti kübar saab täis siis. Võibolla Ei saagi enam öelda et, väga uus on ju
Õpetaja: aga, Kindel on see tõesti loomulik et, see on muutunud. Igal juhul ma olen Super Excited. Ee, jätma teid siia tegema neid ee, kontseptsioone õppima vaata ja ja lähen kuulan siis, mis seal arutuses. Tegelikult räägitakse, sest, et ma arvan, et see küsimus on hästi aktuaalne.
Õpetaja: Ee, see. Mul on hea meel, et midagi on toimumas, Nagu et mingisugune arutus on kutsutud, on sinna inimesed. Ee, Telia ja nii edasi. Kõik Ee, inimesed, nagu, ee. Nemad peavad andma meile tegelikult suunised.
Õpetaja: Kuidas te nüüd siis tahate? Seda uut järelkasvu või mis? Mida nad peavad oskama Kuidas Mis moodi? Mis te tahate,
Õpetaja: et ee, see Nagu Võibolla lõpuks annab siis meile validatsiooni, et see mis me praegu teeme, on õige. Või siis tegelikult hoopis mõtteid, mida me peame veel Nagu vaatama, onju?
Õpetaja: Tõmbama on nagu pärast seda.
Õpetaja: Ja ära käimisel.
Õpetaja: No minema. Kursus sai läbi, võibolla. Noh, ma ei usu, et selle sõnumiga Need sõnumiga tulevad kohale, et et on kostunud kõlakad. Et juuniori enam polegi vaja tuleb sinna. Nii ongi.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, et tulite Kohvi ja sajused on seal,
Õpetaja: lähme minema. Ma ei usu Ee, see ei ole võimalik see. Tegelikult, Vaata, mõelge nende seda. Siin on see nagu hirm, ka, Vaata, et nagu, et, ee. Kas tarkvara arendajaid enam ei ole. Vaja. No mina ise tunnen ka hirmu. Ma tahan ikkagi tarkvara ajada, Ma Ei tea, tarkvara minna mingi hetk.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, mul siin ka saan. Käpad mullas natukene hoida. See mulle ikka meeldib tegelikult tarkvara arendus nii Väga
Õpetaja: või mingi eile öösel ka kell kaksteist. Isegi kell üks veel enam vähem. Olin üleval, magesin.
Õpetaja: Aeg on olemas, Ee,
Õpetaja: ja tähendab, selles mõttes, et ma. Ma tahtsin pointiga jõuda sinna. Vaata, et jah, mina. Noh, siin on nagu see, nagu ikka. Kõik need tehnoloogilised revolutsioonid on olnud. Vaata, et mingi kaariku vennad on mingi hullult närvis. Nagu. Vaata, et. Oi, nüüd tuleb mingi aurumootor ja
Õpetaja: eks Niimoodi ongi, aga tegelikult on lihtsalt see, et see töö iseloom. Ja see hakkab lihtsalt muutuma. Vaata, noh, ai mõttes juba ongi. Tegelikult, mulle meeldib sõna orkestreerima.
Õpetaja: Siin ongi niimoodi. Dirigent paneb niimoodi, et. Et sa nagu annad talle nagu suuniseid asju ja jälgid Loomulikult, täna me ikkagi oleme veel sellises seisus, Kus sa kurat pead koodi teadma? Sellepärast, et sa vastutad iga rea eest.
Õpetaja: Sa vastutad tegelikult iga Jumala rea eest. Ee, siin tulevad valusad, Valusad õppetunnid. Ee, paljudel ettevõtetel. Vaata, Lhv L oli siin vahepeal mingisugused. Ee, tohutud jamad. Mingid maksed läksid mingi sajakordselt inimestel pappi, läks maha. Ma Ei tea, kas Lhv käis vist Lhv liinil.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja naa. Ee, et, ee. Minu mul naisel oli mul endal kah Ee läksid Maksed. Maksime mingi asja eest. Ja spõmm tuli täpselt sama. Makse samale ettevõttele otsa. Vahet pole, ühel konkreetsel päeval, nemad ei ole avalikult seda Öelnud Ee, et, ee. Nad ütlesid, et see on mingi vana puugi, mis kuskilt tuli välja,
Õpetaja: Kui te kerite uudiseid nagu tagasi nagu tsirka, Nagu mingi aasta, Siis oli seal mingi suur bravado. Nad lasid päris palju inimesi minema. Ja nagu ma pakun, ma kurat Pakun, vahet pole, Vana puugi või mitte,
Õpetaja: Kamaan Vana puugi masin käitub täpselt nii seda, mis talle ette öelda. See pidi tulema mingi koodi muudatusega.
Õpetaja: Ta pidi tulema kuidagi koodi muudatusega, et kui vana puugi oli sees. Aga miski pidi seda trigerdama.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga siis on küsimus, kuidas see parandati,
Õpetaja: kui Kui aasta tagasi oli uudis, et nagu. Ja Ja me lähme mingi toodud Ai suunda ja mingi anti seal inimestele põhimõtteliselt et hakkate astuma Vaata, onju? Siis Mina arvan, et tegelikult ee taustal. Kuidagi on ai sellega seotud. Noh, ma lihtsalt ei ütle seda.
Õpetaja: Nad ei ütle seda
Õpetaja: Ee, suuremad prohmakad taastamise asjad. Või siis, kui midagi läheb totaalselt panga. Ee, siis tavaliselt tehakse nagu post Morten. Need asi on postmorten
Õpetaja: otse Tõige
Õpetaja: post. Mortem on see? Vaata, kui kõnged ära vaata, siis on vaja aru saada, miks sa ära surid.
Õpetaja: Noh, hakkame sealt lahti vaatama,
Õpetaja: Ee, siis suurtemate apsakate puhul. Tavaliselt ee, viisakamad ettevõtted või kes on võibolla börsil. Ma ei tea tihtipeale teevad siis ka mingisuguse päris nagu Korraliku avaliku Niiöelda avalik seda analüüsi, et
Õpetaja: kuidas juhtus? No, siin on olnud olemas küll mingid suured. Kogu maailma. Internet on peaaegu maha kukkunud kuskil. No nüüd räägime mingist vanast puugist. Vaata, kuskil oli lihtsalt mingi Interger või Long. Vaata, mingisugune loendur,
Õpetaja: mille lihtsalt mälumahl saab täis, vaata, et seal on mingi ulatus numbrites. Vaata, nagu mingid niuksed. Apsakad on olnud. Vaata. Ja see siis tavaliselt ongi nagu vaja, see suurpõhjus üles leida, et. Noh, kuidas, kuidas sai see tulla? Ja nagu lennuõnnetuse Või keegi vaatab
Õpetaja: hästi põnev saade National Discover It. Ma ei tea, mis iganes. Iga kord, kui mingi lennuk alla kukub, onju, siis on mingi põhjus, miks see lennuk alla kukkus. Aga tavaliselt ei ole kunagi see Nagu Nii simpel. Vaata, et seal ei ole nagu mingi üks põhjus, vaid on mingisugused kokkulangevused.
Õpetaja: Tarkvaras on ka tegelikult pigem on võibolla niimoodi et mingid mitu asja langevad kokku. Ee, halval ajal ja realiseerub mingisugune asi, mida ette ei osanud lihtsalt näha.
Õpetaja: Mul on kõik osad ära näinud? On Jah,
Õpetaja: no kunagi töötasin Eurospace ettevõttes ka. Võibolla sai ka hästi. Natuke kuidagi,
Õpetaja: kui ülemist koguaeg ütled. Sa tead seda? Passin neid Kogu aeg ja asjad. Aga kas sa hakkad mingi lennuki inseneriks? Kus sul neid vaja vaadata meeldis? Mu naine kardab lendamist.
Õpetaja: Ma olen nädal vaadanud koos vaatama. Lihtsalt vaatad ju, et kõik, need probleemid on juba ära käidud. Nagu et rohkem tuleb
Õpetaja: Mina olen. Kuule, tehke Flight Raider lahti
Õpetaja: lahti. Vaadake, kui palju lennukeid? Ee, hakake Zoom ima. No siis näete, kui palju lennukeid on Ühel hetkel õhus
Õpetaja: ja siis mõelge, kas Iga päev potsatab mõni alla.
Õpetaja: Ei põtsata ju.
Õpetaja: Jah, suurem tõenäosus on vist valguga pihta. Saada, kui lennukiga alla kukkuda.
Õpetaja: Kuigi, Ee, ma ei, ma Ei, tea, kas on legend või mitte et oli mingi tüüp, kes on on kaks korda või Kolm korda on halb, Seda ma Ei, tea, see on juba. Läheb juba üle võli. Aga põhimõtteliselt. Ja mingi tüüp, kes on kolm korda lennukiga alla kukk on taga ellu jäänud,
Õpetaja: et statistiliselt ta võib terve ülejäänud elu lihtsalt lennukis istuda Idee järgi. Nüüd oleks surnud ilmselt praegu ja pihta ei saa, aga nüüd Tuleb välja, et isegi hauakivi tuleb lennuki. Aa, okei, okei.
Õpetaja: Ei, aga lennukiga. Ja on mingi vend, kes nagu survive. Mitu korda see lihtsalt See on statistiliselt on nii väike tõenäosus, aga loomulikult asju. No ma vaatan ka. Noh, selles mõttes et ma pakun tegelikult siin isegi tulevikus, on järjest rohkem nagu muresid.
Õpetaja: Software tarkvara. Kõik on nii ära automatiseeritud.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt meediad lähevad varsti lennukisse, Vajutavad start onju, siis maanduvad, panevad kinni Lähme koju, et. Noh, aga nüüd kui hakkavad asjad nihu minema, vaata siis, nagu keegi ei oskagi hästi lennata. Ja pluss, ega Mis meil Oli see kolm? Ee, seitse, kolm, seitse maksti.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis see nüüd? Kaks tükki riburada pidi? Tegelikult poole aasta sees kukkusid alla. Software tarkvaras Oli viga,
Õpetaja: et ee. Teatud tingimustel põhimõtteliselt tarkvara hakkas ee siis ise niiöelda kontrollima seda, et Pitch alla panna
Õpetaja: ja. Aga see ei ole See, mille mis on nagu tarkvaraga seotud.
Õpetaja: Piloodid pidid võitlema seda, et lennupi ütleb, et ma lähen alla. Nii ülesse ei lähe, pani linn Tõusul pani linn sisse niimoodi, et ta lõi selle senderi paigast ära. Ja siis.
Õpetaja: Jah. Okei, Selles mõttes mõte. On õige Jah, Point oli See, et kaks sensorit, on pitooturukesed niuksed, väiksed, mis saavad rõhku ja kiirus. Niimoodi see lennuk ees
Õpetaja: teavad. Seda. Ja. Ja. Ja ee, et Ühesõnaga point oli seal, see, et mis see tarkvara oli, see, et tarkvara ei osanud händida seda olukorda. Kui üks nendest kahest näitab erinevaid andmeid
Õpetaja: nagu vale andmeid.
Õpetaja: Et see peaks olema nagu automaatselt. Läheb nagu kuulan. Ainult seda Arvestan ainult sellega, niuke. Võimalus ja seal oli siis Nagu mingi. Ütleme niiöelda pikalt. Mingisugune
Õpetaja: kogu asi sai sellest, et nad tegelikult disainisite. Ee, lennukile nüüd uued suured mootorid. Vana kere ei tahtnud muuta. Ee, siis, ee. Lennuki mootorid tulid madalamale raskuskese muutus
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd. Mis on see, et vaata aerodünaamika? Vaata, kui sul enam loomulikult lennuk ei ole tasakaalus. Siis lihtsalt peab lahendama tarkvaraga. Ära et hoia, ennast koguaeg balansis. Aga tarkvara see oli siis Noh, nii. Kuulge, tuleme tänasesse, päeva.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma jagan teile pärast siis need teemad ära. Aga ma teen seda mingi peale vahetundi. Hästi, korra veel nokitseks selle kallal.
Õpetaja: Ee, Hakkame nüüd ee. Toimetama. Ee, Zoom is ongi kõik. On Ee, Teeme oma töövahendid lahti.
Õpetaja: Ma korra piilun. Hästi korraks lihtsalt seda, et, ee, Paljud siis silmad alla panid, kes jõudsid?
Õpetaja: No, Kümme, inimest peale minu. On veel ka öelnud et, nad ee Kid Brunchide Kohta ühtteist ee. Oskavad.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan praegult selle Copy base. Kogu sellest. Ee, jutust siin.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, nüüd asi. Ee, ma teen lahti. Pank. Ee Mitu tükki, Näiteks fond.
Õpetaja: Ah see on õige. Nii
Õpetaja: Nii jõudsime eile põhimõtteliselt siiamaani, et me saime üldse oma rakendus. Me hakkasime näitama seda harude värki
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, ee, alustan. Ee, nendest asjadest. Mis asi on Kid Checkout.
Õpetaja: Keegi ei saa, on täitsa oma sõnadega mida iganes võita üleklassi hõigata.
Õpetaja: Jaa, Branch I vahetus, et ee. See süsteem on niimoodi. Et, ee. Kui me soovime Faile kuhugi salvestada, siis siis me peame olema aktiivsed selle
Õpetaja: nagu haru peal. Mõelge sellest nagu niimoodi. Nagu puu on. Puu kasvab. Puul on oksad.
Õpetaja: Ee, sina tahad? Näiteks, ee. Võtta ühelt ee, Oksalt õuna puu otsas. Niimoodi tundub ebaturvaline, Aga lapsed ikka teevad. Ja siis kas nad ka teevad,
Õpetaja: et kui sa tahad mingit õuna mingit Ee, mingit muudatust teha. Vaata Mingis konkreetses. Ee Niiöelda harus. Siis sa pead olema Ütleme siis vähemalt selles kontekstis selle haru peal, sööd oksa peal ja võtad õuna, näiteks? Noh, vähem. Ee, Siis Checkout teeb seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, checkout Ka checkout I teha. New Branch. Kuidas see oli üldse?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult saabki kahte asja teha ta saab ka uue haru luua,
Õpetaja: et kui ma praegu. Ee Vaadake seda tööriista siin, näete seda nagu see on nagu ajajoon ja üks mummu.
Õpetaja: See tähistab tegelikult Comiti selle tööriista nimi. Need on kõik toolid siin. Kui vaadata View ja Tool Windows, Et mis erinevad toolid meil siin kõik on nähtaval See konkreetselt. See tool on. Tööriist
Õpetaja: on tool, Window,
Õpetaja: aga ma kutsun neid ka vahel paneelideks. Vaata, mulle meeldib ka nii kutsuda neid. Kui te tulete siia alla, siis siin Ta näitab, et võrreldes viimase salvestuspunktiga siin selle, harus, Kus me praegu oleme? Ta näitab? Kus on mingeid muudatusi. Kas teil on mingeid muudatusi?
Õpetaja: Nii Vaadake, kui ma teen kuskil näiteks siin indeksfailist, Teen ühe niiöelda muudatuse. Mingisugune
Õpetaja: siis siia alla. Automaatselt Ee, ilmuvad need failid, kus need muudatused toimuvad
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see see integreeritud arenduskeskkond See idea on siis integreeritud Kit i programmiga ja tema oskab meile visualiseerida ja kogu aeg näidata, et mis toimumas on, nagu mõnus, vaata, Aa, okei, Siin on muudatus, onju
Õpetaja: nii? Okei, nüüd, Aa, mida meie tahame teha, on see, et, ee, meie esialgu toimetame oma arvutis,
Õpetaja: kui Ma räägin oma arvutist siis kui me vaatame siit niukest. Ee, ma ei tea kuidas seda tööriista kutsuda, kui teil on kui mitu see On lihtsalt kitul
Õpetaja: ee siit alt lahti teha. Siit on võimalik näha. Ee, kõike harusid, mis hetkel on meie arvutis ja mis on hetkel Remote is
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, see. Anna meile nagu ülevaate
Õpetaja: siin. Võibolla sa oled vaja vale selle peal. Vaata, siin on.
Õpetaja: No see järjekord võib nagu paigas ka olla. Ma ei tea, kas viimane või eelviimane. Kuidas teil on
Õpetaja: viimane? Tavaliselt on klassikad siin vahel kogemata. Räägi rääkimisega Võid ise neid nagu paigast ära lükata ja. Nii. Okei,
Õpetaja: nii, ee, Nüüd üks, asi mis mina nüüd. Kõigepealt tahan, et te saaksite aru, Vahet pole? Kas Master? Ee, Local Master Remote, onju? Siis see praegult. Kogu see osa, mis me siin näeme, Tegelikult füüsiliselt failide mõttes on Meie Arvutus
Õpetaja: meil on hetkel põhimõtteliselt koopia sellest, et mis toimub pilves, mis pilles praegult on?
Õpetaja: Mis failid seal, on mis arutel on ja nii edasi. Aga me ei näe seda nagu reaalajal. See Remote ei lähe nagu niimoodi internetti ja ütleb, et seal on midagi,
Õpetaja: vaid meil on Lihtsalt see hetkeseisv. Mingil hetkel me oleme nupuvajutusega öelnud, et palun lihtsalt sünkroniseeri. Ja nagu kuva. Noh, võta nagu kõige viimane seis internetist, mis Sealt ee on, Aga ta hoiab seda füüsiliselt. Meie arvamus. Seda on vaja aru saada.
Õpetaja: Nii, no nagu keeruline. Aga kuidagi proovime sellest aru saada.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kui mina näiteks praegult lähengi.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen praegult.
Õpetaja: Ee, vahetan ära, et lähen Bcs I peale.
Õpetaja: Tüütu on see Pendeldamine. What can you do?
Õpetaja: Nii, tulen otsin ülesse selle sama repositooriumi. Noh, ka teil on ligipääs Tegelikult sellele Repole Te olete seal projekti Osaliselt, kui te olete sisse loginud.
Õpetaja: Ma teen lihtsalt siin pulli pärast ühe uue haru juurde. Ee, kuidas siin üldse saab haru teha?
Õpetaja: Äkki View All Branches alt pakub veel võimalust. Näe, New Branch.
Õpetaja: Ma panen lihtsalt. See on vaatamise kohta. Teist. Üks, kaks, kolm, rate, New Branch,
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema tegi sellest samast. Tegi lihtsalt ee. Juurde ühe uue haru.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan, kus ma nüüd saan seda vaadata, et nüüd on siin Kaks aru
Õpetaja: on master ja test. Üks, kaks, kolm. Olete nõus.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: kui ma praegu teen nüüd lahti ja tulen, vaatan, et siin nagu seda Kit I tööriista Remote I all. Kas siin on mul see test? Üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Ei, miks ta ei ole?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ei ole uuendanud. Mäletate, ma rääkisin teile sellest punasest joonest, et kithab meie arvuti
Õpetaja: siit info Kunagi ei liigu kuidagi automaatselt. Need asjad ei ole Connected, Kui need asjad oleks Connected nagu omavahel niimoodi. Nagu eriti veel Nagu serverist Liikus nagu meie poole. Aa, see oleks nagu, et kuidas, minu arvates on mingi asi tulla ja toimetada.
Õpetaja: See ei oleks hea Ja see on hästi taotlik üldse. Vaata, et see on nagu punane joon, Nii, nüüd tulebki aru saada, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, et, ee, et me peame ise. Nagu siis seda meeles hoidma, et need asjad ei ole Sünkroonis.
Õpetaja: Need ei ole sünkroonist.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma nüüd küsin, et, ee. Mis vahe on? Kas keep oli ka seal Ee nimekirjas,
Õpetaja: Mis vahe on Kid Full ja kuulus saab eraldi,
Õpetaja: mis seal on. Aga said täpselt kallid. Liigo.
Õpetaja: Väga hea see on hästi tähtis. Te saate aru,
Õpetaja: Kui mida iganes, mida iganes Kit siin arvutis teab,
Õpetaja: tema teab ainult selle viimase hetke seisukohta, mis niiöelda serveris toimub
Õpetaja: nüüd, et lihtsalt saada teada, nagu, et. Hei, mis toimub, Tall Remote is Siis selle jaoks ongi cash
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et ole hea lihtsalt peegelda. Peegelda mulle Siia alla, Remote I ainult seda. Põhimõtteliselt siin Minu meie arvutis meie arvutis peegelda, Lihtsalt et tõmba endale see informatsioon alla,
Õpetaja: et mis toimub, Tip Hub is.
Õpetaja: Aga mida ta ei tee, on see, et ta ei muuda ühtegi faili, mis on meie arvutis, mis on meie töövoos,
Õpetaja: See. See siin on peegeldus. Näete, siin all. See siin on mingisugune haru, mille kallal me saame reaalselt tööd teha ja on meie töövoos,
Õpetaja: Neid harusi võib olla siin mitmeid. Ehk siis klassikaliselt, kui te teete tööd kuskil ettevõttes. Teil on tegelikult pidevalt Ee, rohkem kui üks taas on käsil.
Õpetaja: Sa tavaliselt juba sellepärast, et sul. Sa Sul võib olla, niimoodi et sa saad mingi asja kallal tööd teha kuni mingi teatud Maani. Sa pead midagi võibolla ootama või kedagi, mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Sa võid vahepeal mingeid muud asja teha. Väga tavaline, Töötad ka mingi ühe kahe asja kallal paralleelselt. Noh, pigem nagu kronoloogiliselt Rohkem keskendud ühele, Aga siis vahepeal võibolla teed midagi teise asjaga. Ka
Õpetaja: See on sinu töövoom, sa ei tohi. Sa ei mõjuta. Sel sa sinu töövoos on on sinu arvutis. Sa ei mõjuta mitte kedagi, Mitte ühtegi teist inimest, ee ega Tiimi liiget, kes ka töötab selle projekti kallal, sest et see on eraldatud.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga nüüd see haru ongi. Saada siin selles lokali all. See haru, mis mul on siin. Me saame teha üldse muudatusi. Siin Me saame kirjutada koodi oma arvutis, mis on selles ee, lokali all, Nii,
Õpetaja: ja see, mis on, on siin, on lihtsalt peegeldus.
Õpetaja: Kit Fetch
Õpetaja: toob kõige uuema peegelduse. Update on juba see, kui on toimunud mingi Muudatus Mingisuguses harus. Mis on seal pilves?
Õpetaja: Noh, kohe Me teeme seda niimoodi ükshaaval. Vaata, et saada seda aru saada kui ma praen, panen Näiteks siia Masterile. Ma siit, et ei oleks mingit probleeme
Õpetaja: on. Siis Ma näitan seda Ka Ma siin kustutasin ära enne. Oli See mingi Aa, vaata, onju. Näete, siin on Niukene Hall märk.
Õpetaja: Siin oli enne. Aa, ma kustutasin ära. See on see muudatus, kui ma teen Roll Back. Ee, Tegelikult see ka toimub Selektsiooniga, mitte tikiga. Tikiga on ainult see kommitimise värk, et kui mul on see highlight itud, teen parem Klõps või vajutan siit. Lihtsalt Rollback I siin. Ta on ka kuskil Kit
Õpetaja: Ee Lihtsam on võibolla siit panna. See on nüüd hästi tavaline, et Siin on, ee, mitmeid kohti, kus saad vajutada nagu samu tegevusi.
Õpetaja: Need on samad, et Kas sa vajutad siit
Õpetaja: Shortcut Iga vajutad siia, Kliki. Vajutad siia parema klõpsu. Tuled siia, Kitt ja paned roll. Backs on ikka sama. Sa räägid harumajandus seda vä
Õpetaja: siin. Noh, kõik on Samad kõik on samad
Õpetaja: päeva. Lõpuks ta nüüd veel avab. Ta veel Avab Eraldi aknas on nagu see, et ta veel annab võimaluse taganeda ka. Esiteks, see on üsna destruktiivne. Äkki ma tahtsin vajutada.
Õpetaja: Läheks mingi tööga nahka, et ee, Kui on mitmeid faile, siis tegelikult siit saad ka veel valida. Vaata
Õpetaja: ja roll, Back. Mis ta teeb, kui te nüüd keskendute sellele Reale üheksa siin
Õpetaja: vaid ta on üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: Noh, ta lihtsalt taastab. Vaata, viimase aja selle faili viimase nagu salvestuspunkti tagasi. Väga mõnus. Väga hea tööriist.
Õpetaja: Nii ma nüüd roll back isi Lihtsalt sellepärast, et ee, teha asju turvaliselt, Kui ma tulen praegult.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma praegu tulen. Ee, siin See master. Tegelikult see master, mis meil on. Siin On see sama master. Siin saate aru on ju?
Õpetaja: See on meie töövoos. Ee aru, mille kallal me saame tööd teha, Kui ma tulen siia, panen. Ee, kit. Aa, update. See on Update Project Taustal teeb?
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja. Teada. See on see on see, mis ma just arvutasime. Mis on vahe
Õpetaja: Update project on see, et ei pilves. Selles on mingi muudatus.
Õpetaja: Tõmba see minu töövoogu minu haaruse sisse. Kui Ma panen praegu Update Project, siis vaatame. Jälgime Just seda. Remote I,
Õpetaja: Mis peab juhtuma siin Remodis. Kui ma. Vajutan, update Project, Mis Te pakute, ei tule. Nad ei tule
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see ei ole see tegevus, et Anna, see ei ole. See ei ole see, et anna mulle peegeldus. Mis toimub seal? Seal on niimoodi. Et Hei,
Õpetaja: praegult praeguse seisuga kõik, mis on siin selles masteris muudatused Tõmba siia, Vot see on praegult see. Update projekt.
Õpetaja: Ta. Ta ei saa teha Tipp Bulli ta samamoodi. Ta ei lähe iseenesest sinna serverisse, et tõmba mulle muudatus sisse. Sa pead kõigepealt selle peegelduse saama Ja alles siis saad. Kui see Tegelikult tähendab see nagu seda, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ma saan teha kronoloogilises järgnevuses, et ma kõigepealt ee tõmban selle masterprojekti sealt servist alla. Kui ma õige
Õpetaja: ja see järjekord on, õige, Vaata, Point on see. Vaata, et ma teen. Nüüd ma teen hästi selle nagu konkreetsemaks, veel et Las olla meil see üks haru. Ma lähen praegult master Haru peale ja ma võtan, ee, sama indeks Atml i ette.
Õpetaja: Ja teen praegult siin ühe väikse. Ei, keegi seda kunagi ei tee. Aga Kujutame ette. Mingi teine arendaja tegi tööd ja lükkas selle Masterisse.
Õpetaja: Kirjutan siia nagu juurde, tegin mingi uue asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, arendaja X saate mõttes aru, on ju?
Õpetaja: Tööd tuli juurde. Noh, see ei käi niimoodi. Vaata, on ju? Aga ma lihtsalt. Praegu teen nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Minu küsimus on nüüd uuesti kui mina olen praegult siin masteri peal ja ütlen, update projekt, mis taustal teeb? Käsu, Kit Bull. Näete, võibolla ta teeb mitu käsku korraga. Võibolla teeb Fetch I ka. Ma ei teagi, kus mul Kit Bull on Polegi, ju
Õpetaja: seda ma ei teinud aga ometi Kaili teadis. Kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Aa, seal oli. Selle kohta oli mingi õpetus. No ma ei saa peast enam. Ei mäleta. Vaatame, mis juhtub, Sellepärast ma teen korra selle konsooli ka lahti. Ee, see on siin. All On nagu konsool, mis siis näitab kõike käske, mis läheb. Ma nagu, ma ei Mäleta peast, mida? Mida intellige ei tee,
Õpetaja: Mida ta teeb. Tegelikult update Project iga. Kas ta teeb ainult kidpool I või ta paneb kaks käsku sinna juurde. Vaatame, paneme update. Projekt
Õpetaja: Merch, Incoming Changes, Intercurrent. Prince. See ongi see et põhimõtteliselt, et sissetulevad muudatused
Õpetaja: nii sisse tulevad muudatused Sulata need olemasolevasse branži, mille peal ma olen.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis aga praegult võiks justkui mõte olla see, et ta teeb seda, on ju nii,
Õpetaja: Sest et, noh, see on nagu see soov meil ka enda. Aga tegelikult ma ütlen taustal. Ta lihtsalt vaatab lihtsalt neid kahte
Õpetaja: haru
Õpetaja: võrdleb Omavahel tema ütleb, et Merchi selle peegeldus siia sisse. Ehk siis meil ei tohiks seda Pbd sisse tulla. Välja Arvatud kui ta, teeb siin Enne ära niiöelda. No vaatame, mis juhtub. Kuule, panen. Update. Ma võin siit. Kas vajutad siit või vajutad siit? Vahet pole see üks, see On üks sama update
Õpetaja: Ee käsi püstoli, teine variant. Paned peale nii punkti
Õpetaja: prebase. Räägime sellest kunagi hiljem. Ee, Hea asi. Ka
Õpetaja: Ja siis, Kui meil on seda vaja
Õpetaja: Ee, aga vajutab Nüüd Update I
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis konsoolis läheb. Ah kurat, mis ta tegi?
Õpetaja: Näete, mis ta tegi taustal ära Ja siis ära vaata. Ja Ja siis tõmbas. Tegi selle. Liigutuse, ära. Et Kui ma nüüd tulen uuesti siia juurde, siis ma Näen, et see, ee, see sama kommit. Vaata,
Õpetaja: see Pbb tuli sisse. Vaata aga, ma nüüd teen teistmoodi. Ee, ma nüüd teen seda teistmoodi
Õpetaja: Ma ikkagi tahan tõestada seda. Vaata, et, ee. Ja ta tege. No okei. Nüüd. Tähendab, ei ole. Meil ei ole vaja Meil endal on meeles see. Vaata, et Ee teeb alati ise ära. Aga minu soovitus on niikuinii alati. Tehke alati Fedge ise. Ära.
Õpetaja: Vaadake ennem, kas on mingeid muudatusi, et ee, kui ma tulen uuesti siia selle tööriista alla, onju, et meil on siin see test. Üks, kaks, kolm, ma teen Ühe haru juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas see nüüd käis? Ee, lähme siia. Projekti alla.
Õpetaja: Brunches.
Õpetaja: Ee, view All Branches. Ja siin on see nupp New New Branch
Õpetaja: test. Ee, Noh, paneme Niukse Devilish Kuus, kuus, kuus või Branch,
Õpetaja: et tõesti näidata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ahah, ee, mul on mingi mõte, veel. Ee, ma teen ikkagi kaks asja korraga. Ee, mul on plaanis nagu teistmoodi teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen ikkagi väikse muudatuse ka kuhugi, Ee, Ja teen selle sinna Masteri alla.
Õpetaja: Võtan jälle selle vana hea indeks. Atml I. Mida me siin lõhume?
Õpetaja: Ee, panen siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Seitse C, Veel üks asi
Õpetaja: nii suuremaks ka.
Õpetaja: Aga Mid Changes? Ee, üks asi. Message. Mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Nii ee.
Õpetaja: Tipp on It Command peast ei tea isegi, Sest et ma kunagi ei tee seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, Aa. Ja ma ei taha kui mitte teha. Kick Bulli.
Õpetaja: Kurat, lihtsalt teeme lihtsamalt.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle
Õpetaja: kit. Ee, pull
Õpetaja: vist ei mäleta. Masterit on ka. Vaata, ongi lihtsalt see, kui tahad täpsemalt määrata. Okei, see on juba vaata
Õpetaja: näete seda, et, ee, ma tegin mu. Vaatame korra üle. Vaata ma tegin muudatuse. Ee, siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, indeks. Html I On see Ccc veel üks asi
Õpetaja: nüüd hetke seisuga. Siin ei ole Selle komitee nimi oli ka mingi veel üks asi. Näete, komitee nimi oli viimane. Veel üks, asi,
Õpetaja: Ee, hetkel seda siin ei ole.
Õpetaja: Seda ei ole. Kui ma teen lihtsalt need käsu realt. Loodan, et täna käsu kuradi jama selle käsu Reaga on.
Õpetaja: Ee, midagi mulle puhkust. Ee, ei taha.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan näidata Lihtsalt midagi. Et saaksite aru.
Õpetaja: Ma korra muudan. Shellbhat I ära Cmd Ks, et mul on tunne, et tal on mingisugune error sellega.
Õpetaja: Nii, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Vaata, ma olen siin. Projektis. Ee, mida iganes. Ma annan ise siit selle käsu Mitte Kid Bull. Ee, Ja on see, et see haru, mille peal hetkel oled.
Õpetaja: Tõmba sisse uuenduse nagu töö siia peaks justkui tulema juurde. See Ccc ja nii edasi, on ju? Ma vajutan seda.
Õpetaja: Tuli ikka.
Õpetaja: Kas ta ikkagi teeb? Ee, kittpulg.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: aa, Okei, sellest ei saa mööda okei, Ee, tühja teemaga Ee, et ta teeb selle alati ära. Aga. Aga nüüd ütleme siis, mis meile meid nagu huvitab, on see, et
Õpetaja: see annab meile alati teada seda. Vaata, et, ee, mis seis on meie harudega. Selles mõttes, et need harud, Mis meil on? Niiöelda, mis on meie töövoos? Kutsume seda näiteks niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et Kas seal on midagi sisse tulemas
Õpetaja: või oled sina midagi ja Sa pole et sa pole nagu välja läinud. Kuidas ta teeb? Ta lihtsalt teeb nagu võrdlusi. Niiöelda, ta vaatab niiöelda seda haru selle haru vastu. Ehk siis, kui mina teen nüüd siia juurde. Ee, ühe Comiti veel.
Õpetaja: Ja seekord ma ei tee seda pulli. Ma lihtsalt teen sellest Samas arus, Ddd.
Õpetaja: Ma panen Comit. Changes on komitee nimeks lihtsalt Ddd.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd ma näitan. Vaatame, vaatame, mis teistpidi ma ei saa pulliga seda näidata ka Fletsiga. Ma saan ikkagi näidata.
Õpetaja: Kui mina teen. Noh, teen taustal ära,
Õpetaja: siis praegult Tema ütleb seda, et, ee, siin selles Masteris. Kui ma klikin on Ddd, näete, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma lähen enda lokali peale, teen topelt klõpsu. Ei ole seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, Selleks ma tegin seda nii kiirelt. Ee, saab teha siit ülevalt sellest harumajanduse pealt.
Õpetaja: Näete seda joont, mis on katkendlik Joon alla, katkendik, onju Punktiirjoon
Õpetaja: See tähendab, seda et ta toob vaid infot alla Ta ei muuda midagi, kui me vaatame. Näiteks, ee, update I Aa, tal ei Ole siin noolekest.
Õpetaja: Aga idee järgi seda võib mõelda nagu päris noole alla. Too muudatused sisse.
Õpetaja: Kas see asi on natukene segane, ei ole raputatakse peal.
Õpetaja: Palun ja teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei tee. Ma jõuan konsolist vaadata, onju? Ma teen siit, Clear.
Õpetaja: See on nagu selle Kit I konsol, Näete siit ja siit. Kui ma panen nüüd seda Fetch I. Te võite vajutada All Day Long.
Õpetaja: No Tal on siin mingid ekstra komendid juures. Aga põhimõtteliselt ta ei tee nagu midagi.
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt redressib. Sa võid päev läbi seda klõbistada, mitte ühtegi muudatust sinu koodibaasis sinu pooleli Olevates nendes harudes töödes ei toimu.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tõmba sisse uuendusi. Mul oli mingisugune. Minu meelest päris hea pildikene Kus oli. Ee, ma vaatan, Kas oligi võibolla see teema?
Õpetaja: See pildikene. Tegelikult, minu meelest räägib. Ee
Õpetaja: teeme selle pildi lahti kohe, kui ta teeb
Õpetaja: Local Working Director, I See on ee päriselt siis harud, kus me saame teha niiöelda tööd ja muuta koodi.
Õpetaja: Kit, hop, copy. Lihtsalt kloun
Õpetaja: Ja päriselt siis see pilves. Roheline pilvekene. Origin Remote. Me Näeme hiljem ka. Kui näete neid sõnu, vaata, siis see tähendab alati põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: pilve.
Õpetaja: No, praegu näemegi Remote Origin. Ee, siis, kui me hakkame kustutama harusid. Kui sa kustutad mingi haru ära lokalist,
Õpetaja: siis tööri Intelligenci tavaliselt küsib, Vaata, seda et siis Ta mõtleb nagu seda. Branch I. Kui sa. Kust sa teed mingi arenduse, Sa teed selle valmis.
Õpetaja: Sa võtad kogu selle töö ja sa Põhimõtteliselt merg Id. Sa nagu lisad kogu selle töö Masterisse. Kus on see muudkui läheb edasi. Edasi, edasi, Vaata, areneb on ju tiimid töötavad selle kallal.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis see haru, mis me nagu ajutiselt teeme. Kus me tahame eraldi toimetada, tööd teha. See on lõpus vaja ära kustutada, Seda Ei ole mõtet alles hoida. See töö on juba seal. Masteris lõpus olemas.
Õpetaja: Siis lihtsalt ongi see, et kui sa kustutad mingi arenduse Haarusid selle lokali alt ära
Õpetaja: Aga mis ta seal? Mis ta seal pilves peaks olema? See tekitab ainult segadust. Vaata, et see töö on tehtud. Ma toon näiteid ka. Vaata, see on hästi ohtlik on hoida. Ee, ta siin on jällegi kogemusest. Räägin meil ikka pidevalt hõigati kuskil Slaki kanalil avalikult ala alandavalt. Nagu ära, et
Õpetaja: kellelgi on see haru. Mine vaata. Sa näed, kelle haaru see on. Sa Tead täpselt, kelle oma. See on. On ju, et siin on mingisugune haru bla blabla. Vaata, et kas see on veel endiselt töös. No see inimene, kui Ee, tegelikult juba on ammu kontrollinud. Vaatan, et Shira tiket on Closed. Noh, see ei ole. Töös
Õpetaja: on vana värk. Vaata, hügieeniks kutsutakse seda Iga Kord, kui sa sa teed mingi harusid, Me teeme ainult selleks, et me saaksime teha korraks tööd natukene, muuta faile niimoodi, et me, Mitte kuidagi seda olemasolevat projekti veel ei muuda.
Õpetaja: Kui töö on valmis kontrollitud Code Reviews läbinud kõik testimised
Õpetaja: ja kuskilt ülemalt saanud ka Mingi Vahel peab ootama. Võibolla mingi välissüsteemide tagant on võibolla mingi väga konkreetne hetk, millega me soovime et see üldse läheb. Live I enne kui See töö pole sinna Masterisse niiöelda Sisse tagasi viidud Niiöelda Sa nagu võtad nagu mingi mingist hetkest koopiat. Hetkel on kõik need failid folderid, Töötan, töötan, võibolla kaks nädalat. Töötan
Õpetaja: nii vahepeal. Teised inimesed teevad tööd ja see master läheb nagu päriselt, nagu ka edasi. Vaata, sinna tuleb uusi asju. Lõpuks, kui on õige aeg ja öeldakse jah, et näeme. Release siis on niimoodi, et see töö nagu lükatakse siia sellesse põhiarusse tagasi.
Õpetaja: Aga tehnilises mõttes see vana haru on veel endiselt nagu alles, et visuaalsete igasugustel joonistel ja nendel infograafidel on, nagu sa näed, et Tuleb nagu niisugune ma Joonistan veel korra siia ka, et igasugustel graafikutel te näete, Kas sellest kõrguselt näete Kõik
Õpetaja: ee tagused ka meil on siin mingi. Mis on kõige madalam punkt tagumise järgi. Võtan.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, Siin on master. Ma Panen siia juurde. M
Õpetaja: Keegi tahab teha tööd, Võtab aru. Saab Tavaliselt siis projektil on mingisugused. Ee, initsiaalid on mis? Tahad projekti nimes? Noh, ee, ütleme, et meil on Fe front n V. E. Backend
Õpetaja: Nii öelda tegemist on projektiga. Ütleme, et on mingi Fp.
Õpetaja: Mingi Ee, üks, kaks, neli.
Õpetaja: See tähendab, see on mingi saja Kahekümne neljas tiket Meie projektis juba. Ei, tiket. Lihtsalt tiket Tähendab, tööülesanne. Kui sa soov see see vot, noh, vaatame siiralt ka, siis räägid lähemalt.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ütlen niimoodi, et see on lihtsalt, et keegi ütleb, et on vaja teha nihukene asi. Ta läheb süsteemi ja paneb, et
Õpetaja: Su projektil on Ee, Frontend on projekti nimi. Ee, kõik Based hakkavad seal lihtsalt käega. Fe ja järjest. Kohe.
Õpetaja: Keegi kirjutab mingi. Noh, see See muudatus vajutab. Enter põmm. Kuus Tiket on süsteemis. Nagu Supportis on niimoodi. Keegi helistab, Kuule, mul. On mingi mure. Vaata, mingi selle vajutab Entry siis tahab? Tekib mingi tiket number. Siin on nagu tiket,
Õpetaja: Nii et võibolla see on lihtsalt kuidagi üldisem. Pikalt, onju? Mõtest, saate aru, Number siin taga on direkt tegema.
Õpetaja: Keegi võtab omale uue haru. Siis see tal on Nagu Niukene hetk, kus tal, noh, aja, ei olnud hästi natukene liigutada. Hakkab sellega toimetama oma arvutis. Ta teeb mingisugust tööd. Ta salvestab selle ära. Teeb
Õpetaja: Sa teed veel natukene tööd. No hea. Tava on nagu ikka. Nagu mitte teha. Vaata, kui mitte sinna. Master Harusse. Ei, Ei, selle haru nimi on F Sada. Kakskümmend neli, see Siin on Master.
Õpetaja: Näe, ma teen selle joone natukene alla.
Õpetaja: See on meie põhivaru. See on see, mida klient õpes näeb.
Õpetaja: See on kõrvalharu. Selle nimi on Master või mail.
Õpetaja: Ee, ajalooliselt on Vanasti oli Master tänapäeval mei midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja siis minu järgneb päriselt Ka Meil on enamasti oma seegi. Ja,
Õpetaja: ee. Kuidas kunagi onju Mulle meeldib, Mul ei ole mingit. See ei ole. Vaata aga mõte on selge, See on meie Põhijoon Siin tuleb veel. Teeme selle. Ma raiskan Paberit tehakse ikkagi Nagu sinna
Õpetaja: ma mõtlen, See see kõrvalharu tehakse tegelikult ikkagi sinna sinna pilve Nagu titta. Ma just meelega praegu tegingi selle praegult kaheks,
Õpetaja: et oleks lõbus.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: meil on pilv. Paneme paremale poole. Rohelist on seal, Mul oli Ka roheline oli. Näe, on olemas. Ee, vaadake seda. Ekraani. Kitarroheline
Õpetaja: on.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei oska piible joonistada. Ma ükskord, et see õpilane õpetaks. Alati tuleb ufood mul kuidagi teha.
Õpetaja: Nii, kus siin jääb väga hea
Õpetaja: ja teen siia punkti. See tähendab, seda, et meil. Noh, ma Teen siia mõned punktid allapoole. Ka Seda pole vaja näha. Vaata, meil on siin kogu aeg tehtud tööd ja samu aste
Õpetaja: nii kui meie Kroon Ime endale selle projekti enda arvutisse. Noh, paremini. Üritan nagu teha. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Anna. Vabandust, see on meie arvuti.
Õpetaja: Kui meie. Nagu Ee, oleme, Nüüd tahame nüüd selles projektis osaleda. Olla liikmeid. Meil on vaja teha muudatusi lõpus, mis tulevad siia,
Õpetaja: aga me ei saa füüsiliselt klõbistada ja muuta koodi siin. Sest see on kuskil pilves.
Õpetaja: Siis mis meie teeme on? Teeme. Siis Me saame põhimõtteliselt selle sama asja, mis meil on siin
Õpetaja: pilves. Noh, neli punkti ka, Master,
Õpetaja: palju kiiremini. Nii Nüüd on Aa arendaja Rein.
Õpetaja: Tahad olla sina või ei ole mina arendaja?
Õpetaja: Vahet, pole. Rain tuleb arendaja Rain
Õpetaja: ja tahame tööd teha. Siis. Ee, see on räim.
Õpetaja: Ehk see on minu arvutam. Olete nõus
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina tahan Ee, teha tööd. Mina saan endal. Teen endal Shira lahti ja vaatan, et mul on seal. Minu nimele on pandud mõned task Id on Dashboard
Õpetaja: Vaatan, et ee, on see kaks, neli.
Õpetaja: Siis Mis mina nüüd teen? Ja oma arvutis võtan nüüd checkout.
Õpetaja: New Branch ja panen selle Nimeks Fee Sada Kakskümmend neli.
Õpetaja: Ta peegeldab seda siirat. Astkenumbrit Päris Päris niimoodi tehakse sellepärast, et nüüd selles keskkonnas, kus nad on, kõik asjad on omavahel lingitud ülimugavalt sealt kõike asju vaadata. Nagu et taaskeella tulevad. See arenduse asjad ja harud ja kõik kõik Vaata nagu vähem.
Õpetaja: Nii Nüüd mina teen mingisuguse arenduse. Ee, muudan seal mingisuguseid faile. Bla blabla. Teen mingit päeva jagu Tööd, Teen mingeid konfliktid, Salvestan endale ära,
Õpetaja: see on minu arvates, kas see on siin?
Õpetaja: Ei ole sellepärast, et mina toimetan enda arvutis.
Õpetaja: Nii Samal ajal tuleb keegi teine.
Õpetaja: Ee, keegi teine Teeb Ee oma arvutis. Ee, samamoodi proovib. Võtab selle viimase seisu, Võtab uue aru. Paneb, Ütleme, tema on juba varem Alustanud. Fe, sada kolmkümmend
Õpetaja: tema Teeb oma töö ära. Oma arvutis pussib selle pilve. Ee, siis see ühel hetkel toimubki niimoodi, Vaata et tema on võtnud siit oma Haru
Õpetaja: tarne võtnud. Haru on teinud. Tööd, on salvestanud ja lükkan seda pilve.
Õpetaja: Mp sada kolmkümmend.
Õpetaja: Kas minul on see arvu? Arvates ei ole,
Õpetaja: ei ole näha ka. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: minu töökoos? Kohe kindlasti mitte, onju? Kui ma mitte ainult, siis ma vähemalt näen, et see seal on, aga minu töövoos on. Tegelikult Teen seda ainult kaks aru. Ma saan maskeris teha mingeid asju. Ma saan selles enda arus teha asju
Õpetaja: Nii, ja tema teeb selle töö ära. Ütleme, ta sai selle valmis. Siis kuidas nüüd normaalses kohas oled? Normaalses ettevõttes Ma ei usu, et Ühtegi ettevõttes. Kuidagi teistmoodi töötab. See on alati
Õpetaja: siia. Ei saa otse komitida,
Õpetaja: isegi mitte oma arvates kandida. Võibolla saada on ju aga pinnas Mitte Siin on Niukene protsess. Vaata, et tahetakse, et Office, et iga arendus läheb Ee. Masterisse ainult läbi. Bull Requestor
Õpetaja: Pur Request tähendab Palvet See on palve. Ma ütlen piirjoonega praegu.
Õpetaja: Siis peaks juhtima selle punktiga siin ma korra praegu sain, siis selle ka niiöelda tinglikult, et mõte On Nagu see, et juhul kui töö,
Õpetaja: on aja joon alt üles, onju?
Õpetaja: See on see missioon. Selle asja nimi on hetkel Ir Pulbrequest palve
Õpetaja: sisse töö tõmmata sellest alust siia.
Õpetaja: Me jõuame veel. Sinna. Me jõuame nii. Aga. Aga praegu keegi on oma arvutis selle töö ära teinud on pushind Pilve pilves on pannud selle pulbriku Hästi, vaata, et ei. Vot siin,
Õpetaja: palun. Mina tahan, et minu töö läheks siia, Seal Kõik lähevad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb reviewitaja.
Õpetaja: Ta näeb kohe selle requestiga ära, et mis on faili muudatused? Sellest hetkest võrreldes oletava selle hetkega ehk siis mida sa tegid
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuleb vaadata seda faili todafaili Selle koodi vaatad. See on. Siis Ta läheb kohe sinna ja kirjutab kommentaare, annab sulle Nagu tagasisidet tee. See parem oleks ka parem. Näiteks onju
Õpetaja: Või siis? Ta ütleb lihtsalt super töö ja väga hea.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui ee, Sealt saab. Selle aktsepti Saab kätte nagu selle pudriga. Niimoodi ka mehhanismid on peal, jälle, et sa ei saa ennem seda tööd siit sellest siia. Ee, ennem kui. Ee. Keegi on nagu pannud nagu mingi linnukene.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui see toimub, ära keegi annab selle Ee, ära, siis see Töö tõmmatakse kenasti siia sisse ja nüüd see joon muutub nagu selles mõttes Nagu päris päritolus. Nagu
Õpetaja: master läks edasi
Õpetaja: nüüd see minu point on. Esiteks on see. Vaata, et nüüd ongi see. Vaata, et see töö on tehtud. Kõik, mis olid. Ee, Salvestuse failid olid muudetud, on nüüd siin selles Masteris olemas. Kõik muudatused on vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on, niimoodi et joonised. Nüüd sa näed seda seda asja. Vaata, et see Haru tuli ja läheb siia sisse, onju? Ja tunne, et seda haru enam ei ole.
Õpetaja: Noh, et noh, ta ju tuleb ja läheb kuhugi ära On ju? Tegelikult ei ole See haru on endiselt seal. Lahti Kui ma tahaks, Ma saaks veel teha mingeid muudatusi. Joon läheb edasi, teen, selle saaks veel uuesti sisse tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Hügieen on see. Vaata, et me ei taha, et meil oleks mingisugused harud seal nähtaval. Sellepärast, et kõik need harud, mis on endiselt alles, on meil seal, nähtavad
Õpetaja: ja mina saan neid halvusid valida.
Õpetaja: Ja kui toskid lähevad juba siukseks, nagu Üks kuus, üheksa, üks, üheksa, kuus, ee, üks, kaheksa, kaheksa, kaks, kaheksa. Saad aru? Selle numbrid lõpuks on juba väga nagu sarnase virvarre. Vaata Siis kõik harud. Kui töö on tehtud, Töö on olemas Masteris,
Õpetaja: siis lihtsalt hügieen on alati see, et kustutame selle ära.
Õpetaja: Minu pikk juttmed tuleb kokku. Vaata kui kustutamise hetkel ta alati ütleb.
Õpetaja: See tähendab ilveharu. Teeme seda näidet edasi. Seis ongi see, et me mõlemad võtsime, aru, on nii?
Õpetaja: Me mõlemad võitsime halu ja me, ee. Ja toimetasime. Tema on oma töö ära teinud ja ütleme sellega nüüd ära kustutanud, Master on edasi läinud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma seda olen edasi läinud.
Õpetaja: Kui me praegu teeksime Fetch oma arvutis,
Õpetaja: siis meie lokaalne masterharu, mis on meie Enda arvutis ei ole veel kuhugi läinud.
Õpetaja: On samamoodi justkui taustal nagu tead, et tegelikult seal, ee, seal allpeegenduses
Õpetaja: siin on nagu punkt ja Ma panen siis nagu juurde.
Õpetaja: Sada kolmkümmend. Ta teab, et tegelikult Noh, see peegeldus ongi. See informatsioon.
Õpetaja: Tema vaatab seda seisu. See see koopia tõmmatakse ka meie arvutisse. See vaste, mis on pilves Aga ainult nagu informatsiooni allikana.
Õpetaja: Vaadake jälle palun oma ekraane. Vaata Saage öelda, see alumine Osa on lihtsalt kohvi.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei muuda meie lokaldaja rektoris asju. Nii, nüüd kui meie oleme oma töö ära teinud, oletame, et selle Punktiga tegemegi. Praegu mitte. Tegime. Ja kõik on sobilik, on ju? Siis Mida me teie saame teha, on see, et nüüd meie saame Push Ida selle oma haru
Õpetaja: ka pilve.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see. See on nüüd see punane joon, millest ma räägin, ei lähe ilma automaatselt. Sünkroonsetud Ei, tee. Me peame ise neid. Tõmba, lükka. See on kogu aeg see joon. On, See et me peame ise kontrollima. Kui meie teeme Kit Bush.
Õpetaja: Näete siis, ee. Meie joon oli põhimõtteliselt siin Mõlemad samast punktist on ju? Näed, Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: võib nüüd seda kujutada ette Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: kui Me push ime selle ära. Siis siin on sada kakskümmend. Neli on olemas
Õpetaja: ja samamoodi, mida meie tahame teha tegelikult päris selles süsteemis on See, et meie nüüd paneme palve nagu püsti.
Õpetaja: Aeg on edasi. Läinud.
Õpetaja: Me paneme palve püsti ja et Kuule,
Õpetaja: sooviksime. Tegelikult, see on nagu Põhiline,
Õpetaja: et me soovime ka oma tööd sinna masterarusse sulatada.
Õpetaja: Samamoodi Keegi vaatab. Meie tehtud töö ära. On see saab ka seda testida, mida Iganes. Vaata, on ju või lõpuks antakse, siis me saame seda teha
Õpetaja: või mida me praegu ei käsitle. Aga mida me saame nagu vaadata, on see, et juhul kui see vend
Õpetaja: näpis ja tegi mingeid muudatusi samadest failidest,
Õpetaja: kus ka meie nüüd oma arendusega tegime aru,
Õpetaja: siis see Pull Request automaatselt kontrollib, et kas ta on võimeline meie töö siia sisse sulatama. Aga kui nüüd juhtub see väikene olukord, Vaata, et me Tabasime sama faili, siis tema enam ei tea. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: et see arendaja lõppseis on ühtepidi. Meie see faili lõppseis, on teistsugune, seda Siis kutsutakse Merch Conflict.
Õpetaja: Merge konflikt.
Õpetaja: See tipp tööriist ei saa ise otsustada, et mis on see lõplik loogika, kuidas konkreetne fail peab jääma Lõpuks
Õpetaja: Siis on selline protsess,
Õpetaja: et ta annab meile võimaluse. Vaata, et me nüüd sa siia tulevad. Merge ja rebase tulevad mängu Ma täna ei Räägi põhimõtteliselt. Siis lihtsalt öeldakse, et sa ei saa seda teha ja antakse võimalus, et sina ise saad hoopis Masteris tõmmata kõige uuema seisu
Õpetaja: Nagu enda arusse ja seal ära öelda Kuidas jääb see nii öelda? Konfliktne fail. Praegu me seda ei aruta, Meie mängime, et meil on Kõik on hästi,
Õpetaja: meil on kõik ongi toolid.
Õpetaja: Noh, põhimõtteliselt Vaadake praegu, et ma teen selle Joone. Ära Vaata,
Õpetaja: Oletame, et meile öeldakse jah, sobib. Ja nüüd võib öelda, et siin selle arenduse sees on ka olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga me ikka oleks pidanud vasakult seda projekti uuendama, onju,
Õpetaja: et seda parempoolselt pulli endal ka näha. Või
Õpetaja: see meid ei mõjuta. Ma mõtlen, et meil tegelikult tähendab meil tegelikult, ee, ei ole üldse nagu Selles mõttes. Ee, meil ei ole vaja. Noh, ütleme niimoodi, et loomulikult selle
Õpetaja: ma siin kontekstis. Ei, aga mida. Ma nüüd tahan jälle öelda, seda, et. Aga minu küsimus on see, et kus meil seal pilves.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Praegu selle seisuga. Vaata, et kas kas meie arvutis on Master Edasi liikumine ei ole tegelikult,
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see. See. Ee, see töö sissesulatamine toimus pilves. Vot see nüüd ongi master, Tegelikult on edasi läinud.
Õpetaja: Meie arvuti. Ee, võibolla isegi Ta on teadnud sellest, et annab meile märku.
Õpetaja: Ta võrdleb kahte, Võrdleb kahte haru. Ta võrdleb, seda, et mis on peegeldus pilvest ja mis on meil tegelikult? Ja siis ta loeb need kommitid kokku. Siin on üks, kaks, kolm, ee, siin On üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus. Aa, siis. Ta saab öelda, et tegelikult su Master on kaks komikti maas.
Õpetaja: Me saame siis endale Selle update või pulliga? Niiöelda saame selle sisse tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Saate aru,
Õpetaja: et see need asjad ei ole sünkroonis omavahel. Need ei ole sünkroonid, See on meie enda tööarendaja töö hoida. Siin on nüüd asjad, Vaata, mis? On selles mõttes tähtis. Sellepärast, et kui mina asja valin, täiesti ära, Siis me tegelikult pilte nagu sellisel kujul ei õppinud.
Õpetaja: Ja te võite kujutada ette, kui on hirmuäratav, on tegelikult hakata toimetama kuskil ettevõttes
Õpetaja: kuskilt Meeskonnast on palju arendajaid Projektid on pilves.
Õpetaja: See tegelikult on väga hirmutav alguses nagu toimetada. Seal Ja see on ühisosa Vahel pole, mida te Õpite. Ee, mis keeled seal saavad olema? Lähevad, on ju?
Õpetaja: See osa on sama.
Õpetaja: Te saate seal tegelikult päris hea kogemuse hulka Julge oma kogemusi kui mina olen omal ajal. Ma olen kindlasti endale ka nii öelda. Nii kaua, kuni sul üks asi on, nagu lahkumisega tegeled
Õpetaja: ennem ei tee seda nagu enda jaoks ka, et, ee, nagu ei teki mingisugust segadust.
Õpetaja: Ei, ee, pigem vastupidi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Saate valesti aru. Vaata, te Tegelikult tahate olla võimalikult sünkroonis kõigega, mis toimub Ilves Nagu selles mõttes. Vaata, et seda peaks pidevalt vajutama. Nagu, et lihtsalt, ee, vähemalt enne Mingit konkreetset tegevusi. Kindlasti, enne kui sa hakkad midagi enda arvutis seal toimetama. Vaata, sa peaksid kindlasti tegema, kui sa näed noolekesi.
Õpetaja: Siin on Veel üks reegel. Noh, ma saan vihaseks, kui ma näen kahte noort.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui te olete. Ma tulen teile appi ja ma näen kohte Nool Üks on roheline Nool Ülesse. Teeme punane nool alla samaaegselt. Siis ma küsin nagu. Et miks ta, nagu ei järgi seda, mida ma Olen teile öelnud, kui te näete neid nooli.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et ühel või teisel viisil on asjad siin kroonist väljas,
Õpetaja: kui te lähete Rohelist noolt ülesse. See tähendab seda, et te olete teinud mingisuguse komitee enda arvutis, mida te ei ole Push Inud pilve
Õpetaja: ei olnud ühtegi Nagu, Ee, põhjust. Miks ta ei võiks seal pilves ka olla? Up Today. Siis tekib mingi töö arvutis. Ära ma toon näite
Õpetaja: kui sul On arvutused midagi siin, see kommit ja siin ei ole.
Õpetaja: Mis on see paha, mis võib juhtuda ja te lihtsalt vihkate iseennast pärast
Õpetaja: ei Näete konflikti, kui teil on töö siin tehtud rets töö vaeva nähtud kolm nädalat. See töö on teie arvates
Õpetaja: Ja miks on see halb, et see ei ole siin, Mis võib juhtugi. Kuidas kohvitassi arvuti peale. Maja läheb põlema.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes juhtub, unustate parooli ära. Ei tea, lihtsalt Ma Ei tea, ei mäleta enam, kui see on sinu arvutis. See on sinu arvutis.
Õpetaja: On paha lugu, vä?
Õpetaja: Ma olin. Vanasti olin see Noor loll. Ma tegin mingeid mitmeid komitte tööd. Vaatan, ma ei tahtnud kunagi Push Ida pilve Sellepärast, et Jumala eest, äkki mingi ee, teine Arendaja läheb. Vaatab, et mida ma seal teen.
Õpetaja: Ta näeb.
Õpetaja: See võib kumab kuskilt pimedusest.
Õpetaja: Mitte kellelgi pole aega tegeleda News and Nonsenseiga midagi ei huvita, mida sa seal teed.
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla võib olla huvitav siis, kui mingi on hea mentor ja tahaks. Võibolla kuidagi nagu veits, võibolla vaadata Aga seda see point on see, et see on väga halb asi. Huvitav asju enda arvutis. Mina olen ühe Eesti energia arvuti saatnud õhtale Ainult
Õpetaja: metsaga öeldes. Ee, selles mõttes, et asju võib juhtuda. Vaata, et et minu mõte on, et me jõuame sinna, kui sa näed Noot
Õpetaja: siis Action Id.
Õpetaja: Kui sa näed, et sul on noor roheline üles, see tähendab, et sul on. Sa oled mingisugust tööd teinud, sest ka ära.
Õpetaja: Kas ta olla seal?
Õpetaja: Mis, Sest, et see on poolel? Narved Ongi see reaalselt Hullu Ongi
Õpetaja: et te saate tööd, teha aga Ta on olemas.
Õpetaja: Keegi. Vaatame nimi näha. Võtke mind midagi või mitte. Kedagi.
Õpetaja: Töö, säilimine Ja nii. Toome nüüd vastupidise näite
Õpetaja: Ee, teil on Masterharu Vaata, arvutis. Noh, Master Haru. Sellepärast, et uut haru võtta, siis kus sa võtad
Õpetaja: Masteri Pealt alati, sest see on see, mis läbi Projekt läheb edasi, kui sina teed ja siis sa näed, et seal on sinine joon. Sest Masterisse sa midagi ei saa
Õpetaja: kui sa näed, Et ta Defetsi Ja näed, et Masteril on sinine noolake alla ja ütleb, et näed mingi kaks kuu, mitte on tööd teinud. Tiimiliikmed,
Õpetaja: siis Ma Tean seda, et ei harju sellest, et kui me sellest räägime. Jah, aga me tuleme noorte juurde tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin pilves ja ma Justkui simuleerisin, et keegi teine arendaja tegi tööd. Tiimiliige tegi tööd
Õpetaja: nii ja muidugi. Ja nüüd ongi see, Vaata, et et ma ma vahel Tulen ka appi. Lihtsalt mingeid muid asju aitama. Vaata, ma näen sellesid igal pool mingi note virrvarr. Vaata, on ju, et noh nooleke siin Iga kord, kui sa näed seda noolekest, on väga lihtne. Kui on roheline üles, siis
Õpetaja: kui on punane joon. Vaata nagu punane nool, alla, Siis tuleb teha happeid
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et et ei ole ühtegi põhjust. Miks sa. Ei tahaks hoida ka oma arvutisse Tartu Teit. Vaata, nagu, et Kui sa kunagi tahaks otse mascarist midagi muudatusi teha. Kuigi see on keelatud,
Õpetaja: siis sa tahaksid niikuinii seda teha Selles seisus mitte siin see Jama tekitab probleeme teile. Kui te teete siin tegelikult aja on. Aja on edasi läinud. Teie teete justkui siia otsa, aga ta ei arvesta nüüd seda. Vaata, et sul on vahepeal tegelikult mingid muudatused. Siis tulevad igasugused konflikt ja probleemid. Ehk siis, kui näed Noolt, siis kanna hoolt.
Õpetaja: Seda rohkem ei näe.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, Kõige hullem asi, mis on see, et lõpuks te teete niimoodi, et te ise ei ole oma Niiöelda neid varusid. Niiöelda keegi teine on tööd teinud. Sina oled kommit I peale teinud ja ma saan öelda, mida tegelikult niikuinii ei tohiks teha ja ei tee ka ei luba ka. Siis võib tekkida siuke olukord, et ühel hetkel on kaks moodi
Õpetaja: ühe aru peal
Õpetaja: üks roheline ülesanne. Puran alla ja siis sa korraga ei saa. Oota, mis järjekorras ma Nüüd pean. Tegema Miks see üldse nagu on, onju? Kas ma Vajutan update. Enne julgen ma push I vajutada. Mis Toimub, tegelikult? See Inimene tuleb enda alla tuleb ennemata. Ja siis Push Ib. Aga miks üldse olla selles olukorras.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas te selles olukorras on, see, et lihtsalt ignoreerite neid noori, et see töölist üritab teile öelda midagi et ei ole sünkroonis.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et ei saa olla. Tead, mingid õpilased on hakanud mingit jama sust välja ajama. Nad üritavad. Kuidagi Ei, ma Praegu ei taha nagu seda teha, aga Aga mis on nagu see, mis on see sinu selgitus, et
Õpetaja: Miks sa seda ei taha teha, Tegelikult ei ole ühtegi põhjust ja see ei avasta. Ja seda ma räägin täiesti eraldi.
Õpetaja: Nad juba. Me peame natuke midagi tegema. Vaata, et panna selle asja juurde
Õpetaja: ja siis seda kutsutakse. Ee, siis selle resolvimine. Nüüd see konflikti asi on selline asi, mida alguses. Ee, minul ka Keegi ei õpetanud, Aga mina õpetan teile, kuidas läheneda
Õpetaja: Ee, konflikti lahendamisele see hästi süsteemselt. Tegelikult saab alati suurt insalt teha. Minul ei õpetatud. Pidin ise pusima. Vihkasin mürtkonflikte, et ei pääse Sellest ma kohe räägin. Miks Ei, pääse?
Õpetaja: Te teete oma arenduse.
Õpetaja: Te muudate mingeid faile, olete Nõus, muudate faile bla bla üldse kommit?
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ta on päris pikad pannud, onju kauem ja ma räägin selle lõpuni. Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee, te Teete mingisugust tööd, Näiteks ee. Ja siis on niimoodi, et ee, ega ükski töö. Ütleme. Ennem
Õpetaja: testimine tehakse hiljem kõik sellised järjekorras,
Õpetaja: miks ennem Ja testimine pärast mitte testida.
Õpetaja: See on õigel teel. Vaata, oletame. Teeme mõlemat pidi. Vaata, kui Code Review tehakse ära. Ee, Code Reviews vaadatab Ainult arendaja seda koodi. Kvaliteeti loetavus, ülesehitus testimist. Koodide ei tee,
Õpetaja: et kas sa nagu. Lood Kas see käitub nii nagu vaja? Seda ta Ei ole tõenäoliselt,
Õpetaja: et et kui tema teeb selle ära ja nüüd testija tuleb, testib ära, vaata, onju? Lõpuks Testa kõik töötajad siis võib Väga turvaliselt poodi ju. Kui me teeks seda teistsuguses järjekorras, et test testib kõigepealt ta ära
Õpetaja: ja kõik töötab, Kurat, ee, teistsuguseks üles ehitsa ka.
Õpetaja: Aga siis kuidas saab olla enam kindel, et see asi endiselt töötab? Testija peab jälle testima.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes see ei ole loogiline, mis see mängu tuleb, on see. Te võite oma arenduse ära teha. Te võite tublid olla, teha ruttu asja isegi ära ja nagu põhiliselt kandida, Nagu väga väike tõenäosus, et keegi juhuslikult teeb täpselt samadest failidest. Mingisugust tööd
Õpetaja: puudutab neid paineid, mis tähendab tööd panna, on ju Noh, aeg on lühikene
Õpetaja: teste. Nende ressurss on piiratud. Pole prioriteetsemad. Teemad? Sinu asi Pirel mind Kaks nädalat ka
Õpetaja: ennem, kui ta jõuab otsapidi testimisse, aga Mis on kahe nädala jooksul toimub? Põmm, põmm, põmm põmm, Master. Muudkui läheb edasi töötajaks. Töötajaks. Töötajaks töötajatakse üldse. Aeg märgib. Teie kahjuks.
Õpetaja: Mida Kauem aega. Teie taas seisab. Seda Suurem tõenäosus on, et keegi puudutab neid faile, mida teie
Õpetaja: oma arenduses muusika,
Õpetaja: Sest et siis tekib see olukord. Et Kui sa tahad seda siia sisse Merchida, siis tal on niimoodi, et. Oot oot, aga see algne seis,
Õpetaja: mis? Kui sa võtsid aru Selles failis. Ta ei ole enam samasugune. Tehniliselt töötab niimoodi.
Õpetaja: See Paig on muutunud vahepeal, kes oskab, et läheb nii
Õpetaja: tema, nagu Ei, Issand, sa pead küll Otsustama. Vaata
Õpetaja: ja et see on nagu vä. See on möödapääsmatu Mööks Konflikte. Peate õppima.
Õpetaja: Ee, jällegi. Vaata, sul selles mõttes on nagu asi. Vahet pole mis skeem mida te teete. Vaata sellise kontseptsioonina, Kuidas, nagu seda olukorda lahendada? Jah,
Õpetaja: kommentaar koodis, vä?
Õpetaja: Ei, Ei, Ei, kommentaar koolis.
Õpetaja: Ee, Clean Coat. Olete kuulnud sellest raamatust Soovitan lugeda kunagi hiljem. Ärge hakake seda kunagi. Pealt lugema. Üldistest asjadest. Räägime Meetodi nimed võiksid olla võimalikud võimalikult täpselt. Meetod peaks ühte asja tegema. Ja igasugused tavad ja konventsioonid. Kuidas kirjutada ilusat koodi,
Õpetaja: mida ütleb Clean Code Ee, See on põhimõtteliselt piibel arendajatele
Õpetaja: Robert, mis ta nimi on? See on nagu legendaarne raamat, mis tõesti räägib headest koolitavadest on ju, Mida ütleb kommentaaride kohta? Kommentaarid on ainult. See raamat on mingi viis korda alustanud Lugemist iga kord kestavad
Õpetaja: ükski võibolla keskelt uuesti alustada, See On vist on viga. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, ühesõnaga. Green Code ütleb seda, et kommentaar on ainult õigustatud Siis,
Õpetaja: kui see on mingisugune informatsioon, mis selle Koodilõigu juures on ee. Selles mõttes. Ee, on vaja teada. Aga see on koodiväli informatsioon
Õpetaja: kriitiliselt tähtis informatsioon.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt Mida peaks teadma, et kui Sa vaatad mingit konkreetset koodi osa,
Õpetaja: mille koolis ta ennast välja ei loe.
Õpetaja: See on ainult siis iga kord, kui sa tahaks Lihtsalt näiteks siit. Noh, alguses te võite kommenteerida ikka oma tööd. Vaata, et see teeb seda ja tootab teda. On ju põhimõtteliselt, kui teie mõtlete, et Minul on mingi kommentaar juures, et segane kood. Vaata, on seal, Niuke. Mingi segane kood. Midagi aru ei saa. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kes sellest midagi peaks aru saama, onju? Koodi peab kirjutama niimoodi. Ee, nagu see poor soul. Sa kujutad ette, et on mingi poor soul, kes viie aasta pärast Peab seda koodi lugema. Saaks midagi aru. Sellist koodi tuleb kirjutada,
Õpetaja: et nagu sa ise tahaks teha seda koodi ja saada aru, sa vaatad, et siin, on mingi miljonlauset ja mingisugused tsükli või asjad. Midagi toimub Nagu midagi aru ei saa ja kui sa nii pea kui sa kommentaari peale kirjutad,
Õpetaja: siis on küsimus selles. Vaata, et. Okei, Sa hakkad selgitama Poodi. Mida ta teeb, kui sa nüüd hakkaksid natukene detailsemalt neid kommentaare erinevatesse osadesse panema, et see teeb seda. On ju siis iga see kommentaar tegelikult tähendab, et see võiks olla eraldi meetod
Õpetaja: sest et Meetodil on nimi.
Õpetaja: Meetodi nimi ütlebki.
Õpetaja: Kood tuleb hakkida tükkideks. Igale tükile tuleb panna juurde nimi
Õpetaja: Ja siis sa saad lugeda nagu Raamatut
Õpetaja: saada. Meil siis tuleb notification. Uued andmed. Mingid niimoodi? Jah, selge.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad sinna sisse vaadata, et mis seal teeb, siis sa lähed vaataks seda. Vot see on see trikk Kommentaari Ma lihtsalt ei kirjuta. Ja. Ja ma ütlen, et see on möödapääsmatu. Te ei leiuta süsteemi pääsete Sellepärast its. Not in your control.
Õpetaja: Kui see asi istub kaks nädalat, võibolla see süsteem suhtleb üldse mingi välise süsteemiga Sa ootad kellegi teise järgi ka Võibolla kaks kuud.
Õpetaja: Sa oled töö ära leidad ja. Jah,
Õpetaja: aga kui sa uuendad oma lastele, siis sa oma seda tehtud töötad
Õpetaja: Kaduma ei pruugi minna. Ei, ta ei lähe kaduma. Oota, ma nüüd räägin. Ma korra räägin siis, kuidas see protsess on? Vaata, siin on konflikt et sa ei saa. Vaata, kuna masker ees on muudatused toimunud ja mitte mingit sinu faili. Vaata, et Ee, seal on muudatused ja Sina tahad midagi muuta ja ma ei tea, Kuidas
Õpetaja: Siis on selline protsess. Rebasest Räägime hiljem. Siis. Tegelikult on hästi natukene ilusam,
Õpetaja: siis sa Pead tegema niimoodi, et sina oma harust kõigepealt uuendad. Ee, selle masteri. Ee, update iga ära. Noh, kõik, mis iganes tööd on tehtud ja Mis Sina nüüd teed, on see, et sa teed Mercy T. Sa ütled, et võta kõige uuem Masteri seis,
Õpetaja: nii ja palun lisa see minu selle arenduse haarusse
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd selle tegevuse käigus. Ta annab selle nii. Siin. Failis on nüüd konflikt
Õpetaja: ja siis sa näed mõlemad, sa Näed, mis on Masteris
Õpetaja: ja sa näed, mis on sinul endal.
Õpetaja: Sa oled nagu mõlemad. Ja keskel on see tühi ruum, kus sa pead panema siis selle, et kuidas jääb?
Õpetaja: Sa. Sa näed põhimõtteliselt kolme faili korraga
Õpetaja: Vasakul. Master paremal. Sinu haru keskel. Ütle mulle, kuidas jääb
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd on hästi lihtne. Selles mõttes minu. See tehniik on niimoodi. Ee, kuidas seda asja siis teha on? See
Õpetaja: sina võtad selle Master i Põhjaks,
Õpetaja: nagu võtad kõik Mis seal. On selle sa võtad
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et mida iganes need teised arendajad on teinud, noh, kõik on kontrollitud, nii on Ja nii jääb.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa ainult keskendub sellele, et sa hakkad vaatama, et. Ee, Aga mis olid need muudatused, mida mina selles failis tegin.
Õpetaja: Sa vaatad lihtsalt tihti mingi loogika. Saad kohe vaadata. Nagu et see rida. See rida mina tegin. Mina tegin. Sa keskendud, et Mis mina tegin?
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa vaatad, et. Ahah, okei. Ma tegin mingi meetodi siin. Ma tegin mingi asja. Ma pean selle sinna panema, Vaata, et sa keskend, nagu paned siis selle kokku. Vaata, kuidas jääb,
Õpetaja: et sa siis soovitaks, onju lasid? See See tavaliselt ei ole nii Keeruline, eriti. Ma mõtlen niimoodi, et sina tegid mingisuguse meetodi juurde Mingi koodi. Lõik. Tema tegi mingi meetodilõigu juurde. On ju
Õpetaja: lihtsalt see kikk Ise Ei oska öelda, et. Noh, üks läheb siia, teine läheb alla sealt juurde. Lihtsalt nagu copywace Või nagu saad tõsta põhimõtteliselt, et, noh, tõsta. Jah,
Õpetaja: see konflikt saab ainult tulla. Siis. Ee, kui ee. See alguspunkt. Sul on mingisugune tekstifail siin. Vaata on ju
Õpetaja: kui sina võtsid ta mingisugusel seisul,
Õpetaja: kus ütleme, oli kümme rida kümme rida, ja nüüd. Kui seda, seda mörsimise hetkel
Õpetaja: ee ta, vaatab, et, ta, seal et See koht, kus sa saad seda tööd viia. Seal ei ole enam kümme rida. Seal. On kolmkümmend rida
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta ei tea vaata. Seal, Tahad ühe rea? Näiteks Ta ei tea, kuidas seda sinna teab. See algseisevas failis on muutunud. Kui see algseis on täpselt sama, siis Kitil on Fine. Vaata, seal oli kümme rida sina. Tegid ühe rida juurde ta. Tahab selle siia sisse möörsida no. Problem. I know how doing
Õpetaja: Aga kui on selline olukord, et oli kümme rida sina? Tööd võtsid te. Saad ühe rida juurde aga. Nüüd möön siis, hetkel praegu seal. On kolmkümmend Rida siis täna see on nagu eelpool.
Õpetaja: See ei ole sama seis ja sa ei tea enam nagu kuidas, nagu minema sa ei saa seda otsustada. See on sinu ees ja nüüd see lahendus ongi see. Nagu ma ütlesin, kõigepealt suurendad enda Master I, sa teed Ee, niukse asja. Nagu Merch oma arvutis.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et sa lahendad ära siis selle tegevuse käigus selle probleemse ee, faili, ahah Temal oli meetod siin ja paneme meetod juurde. Teed ühe miiting
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ilves see sama Bull Request. Ee põhimõtteliselt on endiselt üles antud ülesse ka, et pilves. Et siis on nagu niimoodi. Et sinu. Nagu see harula nagu
Õpetaja: edasi ja pulverpost on niimoodi. Vaata aga uuesti kõik need testid. Ja
Õpetaja: sest et. Sest et loogikas midagi ei muutu,
Õpetaja: sa tõstad lihtsalt oma koodi paika. Aga master koodi loogika, selline muutmine, kui mina Panen kuhugi selle. Noh, selles mõttes ainukene asi on see, kui täpselt ühte sama meetodit. See on ainukene stsenaarium
Õpetaja: et sina ju tegid mingisuguse Funktsionaalsuse juurde. Tema tegi mingisuguse funktsionaalsuse juurde, seda et ma pean leidma selle minu meetodikoha. Kogu Selles peab olema sinna masterisse, kus ta hakkab olema nagu.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on, see on. See on suhteliselt. Seda võib ka juhtuda, et te töötate ühes samas meetodis. Üks sama koodivõit nagu Mingi Mingi väikene kitsas funktsioon, mis midagi ei tee. Kui te mõlemad teete seal muudatuse, siis võibolla peab hakkama vaatama ka teste, aga unitestid Katavad selle ära ja ütleb, et sa seda natuke peaksid jälgima. Sa näed kohe ära selle, et
Õpetaja: siin ei ole see tavapärane see Vaata, Et ma pean lihtsalt otsima kohti, kuhu oma nagu need juurde lisatud lõigud lihtsalt selles. Noh, selle tekstifaili mõttes nagu asetseda, kuhu ma panen ta nagu allapoole. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: sa näed, selle ära Klassikaliselt. Ee, see ei ole nii keeruline. Vaata ja mi midagi katki kuskile lähe, sa Tead, me valdavalt teeme asju juurde.
Õpetaja: Võib tulla näiteks nagu või mingis mingisugune asi. Natuke mingi loogika muutub, et see on teoreetiliselt võimalik, jah. Ja siis pead vaatama. Jah,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, nende asjade pärast muretsed siis, kui sa realiseerub.
Õpetaja: Ee, täna meil on vaja lihtsalt saada, Ma tahan, et praegu saate aru kontseptsiooniliselt, Lihtsalt nagu. Et kuidas see asi töötab? Rohkem ei tahaks selle asjaga. Teeme nüüd pausi ja siis ee võiks pausi, et panime siin üle jaksa. Seda üldse ka olla. Või pea juba niimoodi
Õpetaja: Lõpus Enam ei saanud aru, aga vot see ongi, see, See on puhas teooria. Ee, meil on vaja praktikat. Aa, üks asi on viimane asi. Ja Siis ma lasen. Ee, pausina. Üks asi, mida Te saate siin siin tiimi projektides Saate teha, et vältida konflikte, on see
Õpetaja: iga Jumala kord, Kui üks tiimiliige teeb mingisuguse jupi, valmis siis
Õpetaja: Ta Push Ib ja Merch Ib selle. Master Isse, Teie, nagu ja teised mergivad selle tehtud töö enda enda töösse.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi on võimalik vältida Konflikte või? Kui need konfliktid tulevad. Need on väga väikesed konfliktid. Ja te olete mõlemad pooled on värsked
Õpetaja: See inimene just tegi midagi, ta teab kõike, mis ta tegi. Sina just praegult midagi ehitad. Sa teed kõike, mida sa. Praegu noh, toimetad ja teed, ja kui nüüd on katsus Ühte sama faili. Vaata siis, teil on väga lihtne, aga nii. Aga te saate siis ka väga, lihtsalt nagu kohe, et see on See sinu osa. See on see minu osa.
Õpetaja: Ja te teate, nagu kuidas seda teha.
Õpetaja: Aga kui te teete, seda, te teete seda ka,
Õpetaja: Panete mingi hullu, Paneb terve nädala, paneb oma arvutisse, teine paneb oma arvutis ja siis on lõpus see, et Oota, aga nüüd on kuidagi vaja. See nagu tiimitööna kokku ka saada. On ju? Kes esimesena mersib? Temal veab konflikte. Ei ole
Õpetaja: siis teise temal on raske. Te olete Kolmele tiim ja kõik kolm panete niimoodi. Seda siis see kolmas. Temal ei ole võimalustki, et ta midagi ei hit I seal konfliktiga igal juhul Hit Ib,
Õpetaja: Kui te teete seda stabiilset See on väga lihtne. Käisin püsti. Ma tegin backing ühe asja.
Õpetaja: Sa ei pea isegi midagi rääkima.
Õpetaja: Tegin selle asja. Aa, tõmban sisse.
Õpetaja: See on lihtne,
Õpetaja: et te saate nagu iseennast aidata. Ärge ma hakka vaikselt, kui ma hakkan nägema, seda. Ma ei tea, kuidas seekord läheb. Ma ajalooliselt. Ma pean üsna palju aitama, aga te ei ole kunagi kasutada kasutada. Teile tuleb vist tööriist juurde, et. Ee. Võibolla te pääsete sinna, aga ma ütlen, et siis ma ei näe toimetada niimoodi,
Õpetaja: aga ma kavatsen midagi välja mõelda, et seda vältida. See on teie enda huvides. Tegelikult see peakski olema. Kujutage ette nagu selles protsessis. Ee, te olete üks ee start Up Tulete, startup. Teil on oma idee, mida tahate teostada. Teie veebi.
Õpetaja: Te tahate olla selline äge arendusmeeskond. Kus te teete kõiki asju täpselt nii nagu nad kogenud arendajad teevad.
Õpetaja: Ja see, oleks mida kogenud arendajad teeksid. Teil on selline üsna kiire interaktiivne. Ee arendus, kus kogu aeg väiksed Tükid tulevad juurde. Seal on tähtsus hoida.
Õpetaja: See asi joonel ja ainult arvutis joonel.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: te õpite need head. Tavad kohe selgeks Saate nii palju seda harjutada? Ehk saab. Ka. Vabandust, Ai saab ka teile aidata. Näitan teile kõike. Davai, Aitab, lähme. Ee, Kas ma Recordi ma üldse panin,
Õpetaja: on poolsest jutust peale jäänud. Ma panen nüüd selle rekordi. Ma panen Aa pausile.
Õpetaja: Ee, teie ülesanne on siis aidata, et.